This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析韧性、健身以及在这个奇特的现代世界中建立心理韧性的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是“TWO”percent，在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。在《Look Back At It》播客节目中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to listen to learn the hard way on the aha radio app apple podcast or wherever you get your podcast
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士在进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。而且，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你。并不意味着你需要收听iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方的《Learn the Hard Way》。
hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s the podcast where we discuss the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology so today it's a kind of a different episode I've got some special guests joining me shortly Meg and Jack some nearest and dearest friends of mine. We're going to do a slightly different episode today. It's a loveline episode. We ask you to send in your love queries, conundrums, problems, questions. With our combined wisdom, we decided to answer some of them.
哈喽，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个探讨我们20多岁时生活中的重大改变与转型，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。所以今天是一集有点不同的节目，一会儿我会有几位特别嘉宾加入，梅格和杰克，我最亲密的几个朋友。我们今天要录制一集略有不同的话题。这是一集情感热线节目。我们请大家发来你们的情感困惑、难题、问题和疑问。结合我们大家的智慧，我们决定解答其中一部分。
So I really hope you enjoy listening to us spill some wisdom into your headphones or speakers or however you're listening. Also, don't forget to subscribe if you're listening right now. So you know when new episodes get posted. And a really great way to help this podcast grow is to leave us a review on Apple Podcasts or Spotify. It really helps the podcast grow. So if you feel cool to leave a review, I'd obviously feel very grateful. But with that being said, I hope you guys enjoy the episode.
所以我真心希望你们能喜欢听我们把一些人生智慧倾注到你们的耳机或音响里，无论你们是用什么方式在收听。另外，如果你现在正在听，别忘了订阅。这样你就能知道什么时候会发布新节目了。帮助这个播客成长的绝佳方式之一，就是在Apple Podcasts或Spotify上给我们留个评论。这真的对播客的成长很有帮助。所以如果你觉得愿意留个评论，我当然会非常感激。话虽如此，希望大家能享受这期节目。
And if you want us to do more like this, let us know. Meg is here. Meg, the Uniting Force of Meg. It's her first time on the podcast, Meg. How are you feeling about that? I'm a bit nervous. I'm a bit nervous, but I feel like I'm with two podcast experts now, and I really enjoyed your episode, so I'm glad to join the mix.
如果你想让我们做更多这样的节目，请让我们知道。梅格来了。梅格，梅格聚合之力。这是她第一次上这个播客，梅格。你对此有什么感觉？我有点紧张。我有点紧张，但我觉得我现在和两个播客专家在一起，而且我很喜欢你们的节目，所以我很高兴能加入进来。
Yeah, we've been wanting to do this for a while. I think this is a much better idea than the ideas that we had previously, because it's like we're going to answer people's questions. I feel like you two are very good bestowers of wisdom. Oh, thank you. It's a little bit more guided, too. I have clearer expectations. Yeah.
是的，我们一直想做这个已经有一段时间了。我觉得这比我们之前的那些点子要好得多，因为这就像我们要去回答大家的问题。我觉得你们两个非常擅长给予智慧。哦，谢谢你。这也更有引导性一点。我有更明确的期望。对。
Yeah. So basically today's episode is a loveline episode, where, and I had to kind of explain this to you guys what this was. So basically, I posted on a few platforms and was like, send in your love queries and conundrums, and then us three 20-year-olds, people in our 20 is going to provide you expert advice. So if you did send something in, like,
对。所以基本上今天的节目是一集情感热线节目，在这个节目中，我得跟你们解释一下这到底是什么。所以基本上，我在几个平台上发了帖，内容大致是：发来你们的情感疑问和难题，然后我们这三个二十多岁的人，正处于二十多岁的人，将为你提供专业的建议。所以如果你确实发了什么过来，比如，
please keep your expectations low because we're not qualified. We're not experts. We're not experts. But who is in life? That's really wise. Yeah. Meg, maybe. Meg's pretty.
请把你们的期望放低一点，因为我们并不具备资格。我们不是专家。我们不是专家。但生活中谁又是呢？这真的很睿智。对。也许是梅格。梅格挺……
Meg's pretty good or Ben Shapiro Yeah Ben Shapiro Jordan Pearson as well Yeah He's my fame He's pretty He's pretty
梅格挺不错的，或者本·夏皮罗。对，本·夏皮罗，还有乔丹·皮尔森。对，他是我的挚爱。他挺……他挺……
Joe Rogan Tim Ferriss Oh yeah Tim Ferriss too Joe Rogan Tim Ferriss All of my faves Yeah Just Tim Joe
乔·罗根、蒂姆·费里斯。哦对，蒂姆·费里斯也是。乔·罗根、蒂姆·费里斯。我所有的挚爱。对，只有蒂姆、乔。
The fellas The fellas Yeah Does Ben have a podcast Ben Shapiro Definitely I don't know what it is What straight man like that
这帮大老爷们。这帮大老爷们。对。本有播客吗？本·夏皮罗。绝对有。我不知道那是什么。像那样的直男。
Doesn't have a podcast True And here I am I am I'm trying to diversify Yeah, no, break it up. Break it up. It's good.
没有播客吗？真的。而我在这里。我一直在尝试多元化。对，不，打破常规。打破常规。这很好。
So basically people send in their love things that are going on in their love lives and we like discuss it and try and provide explanations and advice. And we got quite a few responses. We got like 13, 14 people. And we had a little read of them already. But now it's time to get into it. Sounds good. What's your love wisdom to start off with?
所以基本上人们会发来他们在爱情生活中遇到的事情，然后我们来讨论并试图提供解释和建议。我们收到了相当多的回复。我们大概收到了13、14个人的回复。我们之前已经稍微阅读了一下。但现在是时候切入正题了。听起来不错。作为开场白，你有什么爱情智慧吗？
Should we all go around and say our love wisdom? I don't have much love wisdom. Well, you got a riff. Riff it off. Okay, we'll riff. Yeah. I'd be open about that. My favourite piece of love wisdom is live, laugh, love.
我们要不要轮流说出我们的爱情智慧？我没有什么爱情智慧。好吧，你得即兴发挥。即兴发挥吧。好吧，我们就即兴发挥。对。我对这一点持开放态度。我最喜欢的爱情智慧是：生活、大笑、去爱。
Yes, that's a good one. Maybe that could be... Oh, I thought this was a serious. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Live, love, that's fantastic. It is serious, Jack. Yeah, that is. Yeah.
是的，这是一个好主意。也许这可以……哦，我还以为这是个严肃的……对，对，对。生活、去爱，这太棒了。这很严肃，杰克。对，是的。对。
I'm a white woman, of course. I'm serious, but that. Wait, who's live, who's laugh and who's love? And tag yourself. Yeah, tag yourself. You'll definitely laugh. Yeah. Yeah, okay.
我是一个白人女性，当然。我很严肃，但是这个。等等，谁是生活，谁是大笑，谁是爱？给自己贴个标签。对，给自己贴个标签。你肯定会笑。对。对，好吧。
You'd be loved, Jim. Oh, thanks. And you'll live. You'll live. Yeah. Oh, this is nice. So we're getting the tattoos. I'll throw another one out there.
吉姆，你会是爱。哦，谢谢。而你将是生活。你将是生活。对。哦，这挺好的。所以我们要去纹身了。我再抛出一个。
Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. But we'll get it on our wrists or like our fingers. We all come together. It joins up. Wait, but I actually don't think this is a bad idea. Oh, yeah, yeah. Let's do it with pencil first.
对。对，对，对。但我们要把它纹在手腕上或者像手指上。我们都聚在一起。它连起来了。等等，其实我并不觉得这是一个坏主意。哦，对，对。我们先用铅笔画吧。
Love. You can always change our mind. Temporary tattoos. They give me allergic reactions, though. I can't even get a temporary tattoo. Maybe that's your love advice. Oh, that's good. That's good.
爱。你总是可以改变主意。临时纹身。不过它们会引发我的过敏反应。我甚至都不能弄个临时纹身。也许这就是你的恋爱建议。哦，那挺好的。那挺好的。
Oh my goodness. Oh, my goodness. That's a good start. There we go. Well, mine's eat prey, love. Oh, good, good, good. I watched that movie in India when I was finding myself. You watched Eat, Pray, Love, the version with what's having?
噢，天哪。噢，天哪。这是一个好的开始。我们就这样吧。好吧，我的是：吃、祈祷、爱。哦，好，好，好。我是在印度寻找自我的时候看的那部电影。你看的是《美食、祈祷和恋爱》的哪个版本来着？
Julie Roberts. It was fantastic. Because the prey part was in India, and it was really cool. Oh, they were praying in India. And I was in an Ashroom when I saw it. Was it realistic? Yeah, it was really realistic. Oh, that's nice.
朱莉·罗伯茨。太棒了。因为祈祷的那部分在印度，真的太酷了。哦，他们在印度祈祷。我看到的时候正待在一个修行所里。那很真实吗？对，真的很真实。哦，那挺好的。
I had no idea. Anyway, it was quite cool. Wow. Well, now you guys have all summarized it in three words, but I don't think I can. We'll try. I am trying. Love, love you too. That's my love advice.
我完全不知道。不管怎样，这挺酷的。哇。好吧，现在你们都用三个词总结了，但我觉得自己做不到。我们会试一试。我在努力。我也爱你。这是我的恋爱建议。
Love you too. Because I feel like that's what you... Nice try, buddy. I know, I'm trying. What's that name? What's that name? You know when you start a sentence? Yeah.
我也爱你。因为我觉得那就是你……试得不错，老兄。我知道，我在努力。那个叫什么名字？那个叫什么名字？你知道当你开始说一句话的时候吗？对。
When you are... When you... When you... When you... yeah love you too love you too no no no no that is nice it's like reciprocal
当你……当你……当你……当你……对，我也爱你，我也爱你。不，不，不，不，这挺好的，就像是礼尚往来。
makes it's like don't be temporary mind's reciprocal jacks is that he found himself in India and that's why he doesn't need love exactly yeah I'm so happy yeah no I'm just pretty spiritual
感觉就像是，别那么短暂。我的想法是相互的。杰克的观点是他在印度找到了自我，这就是为什么他不需要爱情。完全正确，对。我太开心了。对，不，我只是相当有灵性。
just getting in touch with myself right now yeah I'm just working on myself yeah that was what I said literally Meg before he came in and I was like to Jack I was like yeah this has been fun
现在只是在与自我建立联系。对，我只是在努力提升自己。对，梅格，在他进来之前我literally就是这么对她说的，我对杰克说，是的，这很开心。
but I really need some time by myself. Yeah. Like, desperately. They're cliches, but they're true, aren't they? Yeah. Sometimes you do need to that. I need some alone time. Yeah.
但我真的很需要一些独处的时间。对。就像，非常需要。这些虽然是陈词滥调，但却是真的，对吧？对。有时候你确实需要那样。我需要一些独处的时间。对。
I've had enough. Yeah. I was going to quote Justin Bieber, because he's the king of good marriages, as we know. And I was going to say, you should go and love yourself. And I think that's, yeah. That's good, yeah.
我受够了。对。我本来想引用贾斯汀·比伯的话，因为如我们所知，他是美满婚姻之王。我本想说，你应该去爱自己。我觉得那是，对。那很好，对。
I don't know about that one. Justin Beaver, it doesn't fit in with me. Yeah. I'm a Taylor Swift stand. Okay. Of course. What's a quote from Taylor Swift? She's got a lot of whiskey.
我对那个不太确定。贾斯汀·比伯，这不适合我。对。我是泰勒·斯威夫特的粉丝。好吧。当然。泰勒·斯威夫特有什么金句吗？她有很多威士忌（指伤感歌曲）。
Oh my God, so much. Oh my God. Recent lyric that I've been obsessed with. Two. I'm sorry if you're listening to this and you have no interest in this. But one of them is you kept me like a secret, but I kept you like an oath. And that's just like, oh my God, how sad is that? That's really sad.
噢天哪，太多了。噢天哪。我最近一直着迷的一句歌词。两个。抱歉，如果你在听这个，而你对这个毫无兴趣。但其中一句是：你把我当成秘密，而我把你当成誓言。这感觉就像是，噢天哪，这有多让人难过？这真的很伤感。
And just between us did the love affair mean you two. That's pretty cool. Yeah. Very tragic. But not really a happy love. It's intimate, isn't it? Songwriting. That's not even the...
而且只有我们知道，这段恋情究竟意味着什么。这挺酷的。对。非常悲惨。但并不是真正的快乐的爱情。这很亲密，不是吗？词曲创作。甚至都不是那个……
There's like not even the best bit, the juiciest bit. Yeah, right. But anyhow, those are my favorite lyrics from the new version of All Too World, Taylor Switch version. Jake. Okay, we already got into Taylor Switch and we're six minutes in. Can we talk about how Jake Gyllenhaal is the most hated man in America in the world? You can. What love advice would you give Jake Gyllenhael right now?
甚至都不是最好、最精彩的部分。对，没错。不过无论如何，这些是我最喜欢的来自新版《All Too Well》泰勒·斯威夫特版本的歌词。杰克。好吧，我们六分钟前就已经聊到泰勒·斯威夫特了。我们能聊聊为什么杰克·吉伦哈尔是美国乃至世界上最遭人恨的男人吗？你可以聊。你现在会给杰克·吉伦哈尔什么恋爱建议？
I know. You'd be having a tough time if he's not in a relationship. Return the skull. Like imagine, imagine getting outed like that. Yeah. for doing what he did. Stop finding your girlfriends at high schools. Yeah.
我知道。如果他现在没有在谈恋爱，那他肯定日子不好过。把围巾还回去。想象一下，想象一下就这样被公之于众。对。因为他做的事。别去高中找女朋友了。
Yeah, that's a good one. That's a good one. I think that's a good one for everyone that isn't in high school. Yeah. Just across the bone. Jake Gyllenhaal in particular, but also all human beings. Yeah. Unless you are also in high school.
对，这是一个好建议。这是一个好建议。我觉得这对所有不在高中上学的人来说都是个好建议。对。适用于所有人。特别是杰克·吉伦哈尔，但对所有人类也是如此。对。除非你也在上高中。
Yeah. In which case, go for your life. Yeah. In which case, don't date someone who's not in high school. Yeah, yeah. The Venn diagram, there is no overlap. Yeah. It's two circles.
对。在这种情况下，那就尽情去生活吧。对。在这种情况下，不要跟不在高中上学的人约会。对，对。维恩图，根本没有重叠。对。那是两个圆。
It's true. Yeah, that's funny. It's true. Yeah. That was a really good, that was really solid advice. Thank you. My advice would be, um, show up at your girlfriend's 21st birthday party. Yeah.
确实。对，这挺搞笑的。确实。对。那真是一个非常棒、非常扎实的建议。谢谢。我的建议是，呃，出现在你女朋友的21岁生日派对上。对。
When you said that you were going to go. Yeah. Just standards. Standards. Standards stuff, isn't it? Yeah. Yeah. 21st is coming up guys.
当你亲口说过你要去的时候。对。这只是标准。标准。基本标准，对吧？对。对。21岁生日就要到了，伙计们。
So if my, if my future boyfriend is listening, yeah, be there. Listen up, bitch. Or I'll write a hate album about you. Yeah. It was not a hate album. It was a heart album. Sorry. It was a hard album.
所以如果我的，如果我未来的男朋友在听的话，对，到场吧。给我听好了，混蛋。否则我要写一张充满恨意的专辑来对付你。对。那不是一张充满恨意的专辑。那是一张走心的专辑。抱歉。那是一张走心的专辑。
That was so, I literally, I literally, making the eye just in an eye. He was like, it was not an eight album thing. Well, if your boyfriend doesn't show up, I'll do like a full rendition of the moment I knew for you. Yeah. How he won't show up to her 21st birthday party.
那太……我literally，我literally，在录音室里制作《All Too Well (10 Minute Version)》的时候。他就觉得这不是一张充满恨意的专辑。好吧，如果你的男朋友没有出现，我会为你完整演绎一遍《The Moment I Know》。对。他是怎么缺席她的21岁生日派对的。
And if one of us doesn't show up. Oh, yeah. We will. We will. Because I don't want to deal with the drama that Jake's going through right now. Yeah. So do we want to look at some of the questions that have been sent to us by our lovely friends and people that we know?
如果我们当中有人没出现。哦，对。我们会去的。我们会去的。因为我可不想应付杰克现在正在经历的那种抓马。对。那么，我们要不要看一看我们的好朋友和认识的人给我们发的一些问题呢？
So. Yeah. Sorry, I don't have my phones. So, well, how about we use makes phone? Well, I have 1%
所以。对不起，我没带手机。所以，要不我们用梅格的手机？好吧，我只剩1%的电了。
so I'm also not going to be that much use, but, Jack's phone is literally right behind him. Yeah, sorry.
所以我大概也没什么用了，不过，杰克的手机就在他身后。对，抱歉。
When he says he doesn't. Well, yeah, I didn't want to, because I'm doing a podcast, I wanted to be in the zone, so I didn't want to get distracted by messages.
当他说他没有的时候。好吧，对，我不想，因为我在录播客，我想进入状态，所以我不想被消息打扰。
So I put it behind me. Oh, that's really smart. Yeah. Yeah. But now. But no, we can use mine.
所以我把它放到了我身后。哦，这真的很聪明。对。对。但现在。不过没关系，我们可以用我的。
So, okay, just a quick thing. So I screenshoted all of them and they're all anonymous. Because I had a feeling that like, we obviously know some of the same people.
所以，好吧，简单说一下。我把它们全都截图了，而且都是匿名的。因为我有一种感觉，就是我们显然认识一些相同的人。
Yeah, yeah. And like some of them would have been submitting and we would have known. Yeah, absolutely. So. Go on, Meg. Meg, gets to choose the first one. I actually, I know this one is kind of a joke, but the question, the guy I am dating is actually nice, question mark. Is this for real?
对，对。而且我觉得他们当中有些人可能发过，我们也会知道。对，绝对的。所以。说吧，梅格。梅格，来选第一个。其实，我知道这个听起来像个笑话，但问题是，我正在约会的那个人其实挺好的，问号。这是真的吗？
There's lots of capitalization in there. I think that's a really interesting question to unpack, actually. Yeah, I agree. Jack, I don't know if you have alternative thoughts on this, but I think there's like a tendency to, like, when you expect the worst from people, you have had the worst from people. Yeah.
里面有很多大写字母。我觉得这是一个非常有趣的问题，值得好好剖析一下。是的，我同意。杰克，我不知道你对此有没有什么不同的看法，但我认为有一种倾向，就是当你对别人抱有最坏的预期时，你经历过的往往也就是最坏的对待。对。
You want to create that situation for yourself, if that makes sense. So like there is actually nothing bad in the situation, but you've created, like you are so unwilling to believe that there is anything good that you're going to manifest this, like, weird, bad situation that doesn't actually exist.
如果你懂我的意思的话，你就会想为自己创造那种处境。所以，尽管这种情况下其实并没有什么不好的事情发生，但你却营造出了一种氛围——你太不愿意相信会有什么好事发生，以至于你将要亲手制造出这种古怪的、糟糕的、实际上并不存在的局面。
I've seen so many people do it now. And I think it's like such a process to actually be like, okay, well, maybe this person is just nice. And we can accept that at face value. Yeah, absolutely. It's like you become comfortable with the idea of like them, of people not treating you well. And then when they don't treat you well,
我见太多人这么做了。我觉得这真的是一个过程，你得去想：“好吧，也许这个人就是很好。”并且我们可以按字面意思去接受这一点。对，绝对的。这就好像你已经习惯了“他们、人们对你并不好”这种想法。然后当他们不对你好的时候，
you're like, that actually gives me anxiety. Yeah. Because this is not what I've been accustomed to. Yeah. So it's like really strange. Yeah, yeah. Or there's a, I think that, and there can sometimes be a suspicion about it when past,
你会觉得：这其实让我感到焦虑。对。因为这并不是我习惯的那种对待。对。所以这感觉真的很奇怪。对，对。或者说，有一种，我觉得，当过去的经历很糟糕时，有时对此会有一种怀疑态度。
experiences have been bad. Definitely. And I think that almost leads to you not being a nice person. Like I would say when you're, when you're expecting the worst of somebody. Yeah. And that's what sort of you're internalizing, but you're spending all this time with this person,
肯定的。而且我觉得这几乎会导致你自己变成一个不讨人喜欢的人。比如，当我对别人抱有最坏的预期时。对。这正是你内化的那种心态，但你却花了大量时间跟这个人在一起，
but you're wanting them to be awful. Yeah. How could you give, like how could you be the best for them? It's like quite interesting. But it's also about like unlearning. I think the big thing here is that like in your 20s, you're going to have like shit relationships.
内心却希望他们表现得糟糕透顶。对。你怎么能付出？你怎么能对他们展现最好的一面？这其实挺有意思的。但这也关乎“反思与抛弃旧观念”。我觉得这里最重要的一点是，在二十多岁的时候，你肯定会经历一些烂桃花。
Yeah. people who are going to treat you badly. Yeah. And I think that what happens is when you meet someone who's actually nice, it's like you have to unlearn all the patterns that allowed you to kind of like survive. That time in which you were like, oh, this is what I deserve. Yeah. And it's like almost adjusting your entire self-concept to this new standard of like how you should be treated.
对。有些人会虐你、对你很差。对。我觉得发生的情况是，当你遇到一个真正好的人时，你必须打破并抛弃所有那些曾经让你得以熬过那段日子的旧模式。在那段时期里你曾觉得：“哦，这就是我应得的。”对。这就几乎等于调整你整个人的自我认知，去适应这种“你应该被怎样对待”的新标准。
Yeah. And it's like so almost like uncomfortable because it also means that you have to sit back and be like, oh my God, that whole time that was being. treated really badly. I actually probably didn't deserve that. But I tolerated it. Yeah. And it's like having to sit back with yourself and be like, wow, that can be like a really uncomfortable moment. Yeah, definitely. So that's cool. Create the anxiety around it. Yeah. I think I've been quite lucky. I don't think I've had any relationships where I've been treated badly. Do you think it's more of a gendered thing or maybe? But I also, I don't even think you have to
对。而且这几乎让人感到很不舒服，因为这也意味着你必须坐下来反思：“天哪，我之前一直被狠狠地虐待。其实我可能根本不应该承受那些。”但你却忍受了。对。这就好比你必须坐下来面对自己，然后心想：“哇，这真的是一个让人极其难受的时刻。”对，绝对的。所以这很酷。围绕它制造出焦虑感。是的，我觉得自己挺幸运的。我不觉得我有过被虐待的恋爱经历。你觉得这更偏向于性别问题，还是也许？但我也觉得，其实你根本不需要
have had it. I think if you have an anxiety, whether it's like been from a previous friendship or or, you know, like, an argument with a parent or whatever, a sibling falling out or whatever, and you have that sort of expectation of people who I care about, don't care about me, or, and it can just be, like, I honestly think, like, I mean, I'm not a psychologist, I don't have to. Because I definitely am.
有过这种经历。我觉得如果你有某种焦虑，无论是源于以前的某段友情，还是跟父母吵过架之类的，或者是兄弟姐妹闹翻了什么的，然后你对“我所在乎的人其实并不在乎我”抱有这种预期，或者，这其实就是——我老实说，我不是心理学家，我也不用——因为我绝对是。
Yeah, you know, like people who are born with particular sort of propensities for, I don't know, like anxiety around their social relationships or whatever, like the actually accepting, okay, well, this is a person who, I care about and they're actually just nice and there's nothing inherently like cooked about them or something that I have to worry about and just like accepting that could actually be a really big thing and I think if you don't then you're just going to be like creating a different relationship in your head to the one that actually exists yeah it's quite yeah like you can't change someone else's behavior but you can change your like expectations yeah and it couldn't mean
对，你知道的，就像有些人天生就有一种倾向，比如说，对他们的社交关系等等感到焦虑，实际上去接受——“好吧，这是一个我关心的人，他们其实人很好，而且他们身上没有什么本质上奇奇怪怪的地方，也没有什么需要我担心的事”——仅仅是去接受这一点，其实就是一个非常大的突破。而且我觉得如果你做不到这一点，你就会在脑海里凭空捏造出一段与现实完全不同的关系。对，真的。就像你无法改变别人的行为，但你可以改变你的期望。对。而且这可能意味着
improving your expectations and being yeah actually this is like this is like this new level. Yeah. It is important. Yeah. And there are nice guys out there. There are. Yeah.
提升你的期望，然后心想：“对，其实这就是一个全新的层面。”这很重要。对。而且这个世界上确实有好男人。确实有。对。
And nice women. And nice. And nice. Not buying people. Yeah. Nice people. Yeah. In the world.
还有好女人。还有好的。还有好的。不是买人。对。好人。对。在这个世界上。
There are very nice people. Yeah. But it's funny when you meet one and you're like, oh, like, this is what I deserve. Yeah. Yeah. Really shocking. Because it's, and it also can leave you.
有很多非常好的人。对。但当你遇到一个这样的人时，就会觉得很有趣，你会想：“哦，原来这才是真正属于我的待遇。”对。对，真的挺震撼的。因为这，而且它也会让你……
Like, I think a lot of times people have, like, we were saying this tendency to like self sabotage. Yeah. And be like, I actually don't deserve this. Like, this must be a mistake. Yeah. Or you're lying or. Or you're lying.
我觉得很多时候人们都有，就像我们刚才说的这种自我破坏的倾向。对。然后心想：“我其实不配拥有这个。这肯定是个错误。”对。或者你在撒谎，或者……或者你在撒谎。
Or, This can't be real, so I'm looking for the thing that's wrong about this because there must be one. And I don't think that always has to be the case. Or even if it is, I don't think it's like, even if it ends up that that person wasn't very nice two years down the track, I don't think you can go that whole two years waiting for that moment to arrive. Yeah. Or like for something to switch. Yeah. I'm often in that state where I'm like, well, what's next?
或者，这不可能是真的，所以我得找出这其中的毛病在哪里，因为一定有什么地方不对劲。我觉得事情并不总是这样的。或者就算真的是这样，我觉得，哪怕两年后结果证明这人其实没那么好，你也不能把这整整两年都耗在等待那一刻的到来上。对。或者等着某种情况发生突变。对。我经常处于那种状态，心想：“好吧，接下来是什么？”
Like, when's it's going to chop? And sometimes you like push them a little bit to be like, I'm sick of waiting. Like just show me your bad side now so I can get over it and decide and then we can move on. Yeah, yeah. Kind of sad almost. Not ideal. Not ideal, but whoever that person was, obviously I know who it was, but I'm glad that you're happy in your relationship. Yes.
“什么时候会翻车？”有时候你甚至会稍微推他们一把，心想：“我受够这种等待了。直接把我当成坏人看吧，好让我死心，做个决定，然后咱们好各走各路。”对，对。听起来几乎有点可悲。并不理想。并不理想，但不管那个人是谁，我当然知道是谁，不过我很高兴你在恋爱中很幸福。是的。
Yeah. And also your nice doesn't have to be everybody else's nice, I think, is the thing. And this is like a whole other thing, but I think there's a tendency, especially in like a place like Canberra where everyone kind of knows each other. and it's a very insular sort of community of 20-something-year-olds who are all very connected to be like, okay, well, this person was really, like, I really hated them and they were really awful to me and blah, blah, blah, blah, and it just didn't work out.
对。而且我觉得，你眼中的“好”不一定非得是所有其他人眼中的“好”。这也是一方面。这其实是另一个话题了，但我认为有一种倾向，特别是在堪培拉这种地方——每个人都互相认识，而且是一个非常封闭的二十几岁年轻人的小圈子，大家彼此联系紧密——很容易就会觉得：“好吧，这个人真的很……我真的很讨厌他们，他们对我很糟糕，巴拉巴拉，最后就是没法在一起。”
But that person might, you might have been awful for each other, and that's like, it doesn't necessarily mean it will be the same thing for another person. And this whole sort of thing of like, oh, they were really awful. So, like, you know, I can't be with them because they must not be nice. But it's people have different standards and different, like, yeah, metric.
但那个人可能……你们可能只是彼此折磨，这并不一定意味着对另一个人来说也会是这样。这种“哦，他们真的很糟糕，所以，你知道的，我不能和他们在一起，因为他们肯定不是好人”的整个逻辑……但其实每个人的标准和尺度都不一样。
And maybe they like that. new person a bit more and are like willing to change their behavior yeah yeah but I remember like I don't know if you said this to me or maybe we said it in like a discussion but it's like no one I thought maybe some I think some people are but in general people aren't inherently toxic or bad they just have friction with each other yeah and it's like you know the wrong person for you might act like the perfectly right person for someone else yeah definitely just like huge anyhow Congratulations to this person.
也许他们更喜欢这个新的人，并且愿意为了对方改变自己的行为。对，对。但我记得——我不知道是不是你跟我说的，或者可能是我们在某次讨论中提到的——没有谁……我觉得也许有些人是这样，但总体来说，人们并不是天生就具有毒性或本质很坏的，他们只是彼此之间产生了摩擦。对。就像，你知道的，对你来说不对的那个人，在另一个人眼里可能表现得完全对路。对，绝对是这样，不管怎样，总之恭喜这个人。
It is. I'm so proud of you. Yeah, very exciting. Very exciting. Okay. This is a nice one actually. My ex reach out and wants to have a closure chat, but I have fully moved on.
就是这样。我为你感到骄傲。对，太令人兴奋了。非常兴奋。好的。这其实是个好问题。我的前任联系我，想进行一次“告别谈话”，但我已经完全彻底地走出来了。
What should I do? Should I chat with her or just say I'm not interested? What should this person do? You don't owe your ex shit. You owe them nothing. I'm sorry, like that might be controversial. Yeah. You don't owe them fucking anything.
我该怎么办？我是应该跟她聊聊，还是直接说我不感兴趣？这个人该怎么办？你欠你前任个屁。你什么都不欠他们的。抱歉，这可能有点争议。对。你他妈的一点都不欠他们的。
I think that's, I completely agree. I think it depends on what you want to get out of the next phase, you know, of the dynamic between you two. I think it's a really, really good way to make sure things unawcored between you two. And a good way to even have a friendship with them if you want that. Like I'm good friends with one of my exes from high school and I'm very happy for that friendship. And I'm glad that we did have that closure chat. which happened quite a while after actually um so it depends a while after being the fact that you guys probably had already moved on yeah both of you
我觉得，我完全同意。我觉得这取决于你想从你们俩接下来的这种关系中得到什么。我认为这是一个非常非常好的方法，可以确保你们俩之间把事情彻底理清。甚至如果你想和他们做朋友的话，这也是一个很好的契机。比如我和我高中时的某个前任关系很好，我为能有这样的友情感到非常高兴。而且我很高兴我们当时进行了那次告别谈话。其实那是在分手挺久之后才进行的，嗯……所以这取决于……“挺久之后”其实就是你们俩可能都已经彻底放下了。对，你们双方都放下了。
yeah yeah oh yeah it was like a month two months or something oh okay that's nice yeah yeah um so yeah no it depends on what kind of relationship you want to have with them but then also it's important i think if you if the relationship was nasty and you don't want to take yourself back to that place don't do it because it could be really bad for you yes that's true I also think you get into a habit of like having repeated closure chats. Yeah. Yeah, true. And then it's like, oh, but I have all these unanswered questions.
对，对，哦对，大概是一个月、两个月或者别的什么时间。哦，好吧，那挺好的。对，对，嗯……所以，是的，这取决于你想和他们保持什么样的关系。但同时，我觉得也很重要的一点是，如果这段关系曾经一团糟，而你并不想让自己重新回到那种状态里，那就别去。因为这可能会对你非常不利。是的，这倒也是。我也觉得，人们常常会养成一种习惯，那就是不断地进行重复的告别谈话。对。对，确实。然后就会觉得：“哦，可是我还有这么多未解的谜题啊。”
You're probably never, this is perhaps we're giving advice to the person who's asking for the closure chat. But it's kind of like you're never actually going to get an answer. Like, you just have to move on. Yeah. Like, human behavior is entirely irrational. There's like absolutely no explanation and coherent narrative that's going to explain why your relationship ended. Yeah. And there's a point where I can get rid of.
你可能永远……这或许我们是在给那个要求进行告别谈话的人提建议。但这有点像——你其实永远也得不到一个确切的答案。你只能选择往前看。对。人类的行为完全是不理性的。根本没有任何解释或连贯的叙述能够说明你的感情为什么会结束。对。而且在某个时刻，有些事情……
healthy as well when you like want to ask questions that aren't there and it can just be bad for you yeah i had that i was like you know when you're really hurt it makes sense that you're like i need an answer i need an answer but they're never going to give you an answer and it just can really delay it's satisfying yeah yeah never one you know you've already decided what you wanted to hear and they're never going to say that so i would say don't don't have the closure chat just be like i don't think it's the right time for us give her some chance to like actually heal and And it's yeah, it sounds like by the fact that this person is asking the question they probably Don't feel like they want to have the chat. Yeah, well the whole thing is as well like there's so many it there's many dimensions to this question. Yeah
当你想去追问那些并不存在的答案时，这也是一种不健康的表现，对你没有任何好处。对，我经历过这种事，就那种当你受到深深伤害的时候，你需要一个答案、需要一个解释，这完全可以理解。但他们永远不会给你答案，而且这真的会大大延缓……这很满足。对，对，从来没有哪一次……你知道的，其实你早就决定了你想听什么，而他们永远不会说出那样的话。所以我的建议是：不要进行什么告别谈话。直接告诉对方：“我觉得现在对我们来说不是个好时机。”给对方一些真正能够疗愈的空间。而且听起来，从这个人提出问题的方式来看，他们其实很可能……觉得自己并不想进行这场谈话。对，而且整件事情的關鍵在于，这里面有很多很多维度。对
So I think the first thing is like obviously that there's like in equity in the playing fields, right? Because you've got somebody who's like evidently not over a feel that they haven't closed that door and then someone who feels that they have. Yeah. And then that's where the issue stem from. I think if you're both in the same place about. the situation. I think if you're both coming from an equal place of, you know, I'm a little bit hurt, but I'd like to have this conversation because I'd like to build a friendship with you or because I'd like to whatever. I think that's fine, right? But if it's like, you know that you're going to walk into that conversation and be interrogated for answers that you can't give. Well, then that's weird. Yeah. But I think if you did want to do it, I think it would then be really important to set boundaries, like a really clear expectations of this is what I want to get out of this. What do you want to get out of this.
所以我觉得第一件显而易见的事就是，双方处于不对等的地位，对吧？因为其中一个人显然还没有放下，还没有关上那扇门，而另一个人则觉得自己已经放下了。对。而问题也就是从这里滋生的。我觉得如果你们俩对这种情况处在相同的阶段，那就另当别论了。如果你俩都处于一个相对平等的立场，比如：“我虽然受了点伤，但我愿意进行这次对话，因为我想和你建立友谊，或者因为我想……”我觉得这没问题，对吧？但如果你明知自己走进那场对话中，只是去接受那些你根本无法回答的问题的审讯。那这就很诡异了。对。但我觉得如果你真的想去，那么设定好界限就变得非常重要，比如明确设定好期望：“这就是我想从这次谈话中得到的。你想从中得到什么？”
So that way there's like an end to those expectations, which is really clinical and like gross. But I think it's like, it's one of those things where it's sort of like, okay, I'm going to have this conversation which is going to be difficult for me. I, you know, like my favorite one is like, you know, you book somewhere to go afterwards. So like if you're going to be having this difficult conversation, you like, I've got to be somewhere at 3.30. So I have an hour.
这样一来，这些期望就会有一个终止符。这听起来可能有点太公式化、太冷冰冰了。但我觉得，这就是那种你得硬着头皮去做的事——“好吧，我要进行一次对我来说很艰难的谈话。”比如，我最喜欢用的招数就是：提前预约好谈话结束后要去的地方。这样一来，如果你要进行这种艰难的对话，你就可以说：“我3点30分在别处有个约。”所以我就只有一个小时。
And that way things don't drag on or get unnecessarily. weird it's sort of like there's an end um and if you set out start what you want to cover in that time which is really weird it's like an agenda for like a work meeting but if you set out what you want to cover and you have to be somewhere it can't drag on or get weird or like oh we didn't finish so we have to catch up again it's like no i have an hour um yeah that's so yeah that's actually such good solid advice thanks i think the other issue with like um closure chats is that often And it can mean that that person is actually looking for you to be their emotional support. Yeah.
这样事情就不会没完没了地拖延下去，也不会变得不必要地尴尬。这就相当于设定了一个截止时间。嗯，如果你一开始就列出你想在那段时间里谈的内容——这真的很奇怪，听起来就像是工作会议的议程一样——但如果你把你想讨论的要点列出来，而且你待会儿还有别的事要去，它就不会拖延、不会变得尴尬，也不会出现“哦，我们没聊完，所以还得再约一次”的情况。这就变成了：“不，我只有一个小时。”——对，就是这样。这真的是一个非常扎实的好建议，谢谢。我觉得关于“告别谈话”的另一个问题在于，通常情况下……
Through the breakup. Like, because if they're looking to you for the closure count, yeah, it might just be that they really do need an answer. Yeah. You've cheated on them. Or if something, if you've done it out of the blue, perhaps you do probably owe them an explanation if you can't about this person. But it's also like, I need to have this closure chat. Not because I need answers, but because I actually need you to provide me with some emotional support. Yeah.
这可能意味着对方实际上是想把你当成他们的情感支撑。对。度过分手期。因为如果他们是为了寻求告别谈话而找你，对，可能他们确实真的很需要一个答案。对。你背叛了他们。或者如果有什么事，如果你是毫无征兆地提出分手，也许你确实欠他们一个解释，如果你能对这个人这样做的话。但这也类似于：“我需要这场告别谈话，不是因为我需要答案，而是因为我实际上需要你给我提供一些情感上的支持。”对。
Because it's like you've gone from dating this person, then being that you're everything to going through something that is really hard, that naturally you would actually lean on that person for. Yeah. And so, like, I definitely, I did this in my, I felt my last relationship where I was like, oh my God, I'm so hurt, but the only person I want to talk about it with is you. Yeah.
因为这就好比你原本在跟这个人恋爱，他们曾经是你的全部，接着你经历了一段极其痛苦的时期，在这种情况下，你自然而然地会想要去依靠这个人。对。所以，我绝对……我在我的感情里经历过这个，在我的上一段恋情中，我当时就想：“天哪，我太受伤了，但我唯一想跟之倾诉的人只有你。”对。
So, like, and I think he was probably on the same page. Yeah. So it's like, we'll just talk about it together. Yeah. Well, now, like, the closure chat has just, like, meant that we never really truly, like, moved on or stopped communicating. Yeah.
所以，而且我觉得他当时可能也是这么想的。对。所以我们就变成：我们俩一块儿来聊聊这事吧。对。然后呢，所谓的“告别谈话”就直接导致了我们从来没有真正意义上彻底放下，或者停止过联系。对。
Because if someone, like, ran over you with a car or something and you ended up in hospital, right? Very extreme example, but you wouldn't go to them and be like, can you sit with me in hospital? Like, you know, I just need you there. Like, it makes no sense. And it's like, if someone has actively really hurt you,
因为如果有人开车把你撞了之类的，然后你进了医院，对吧？这是一个非常极端的例子，但你不会去找那个人说：“你能坐在医院里陪陪我吗？你知道的，我只是需要你在我身边。”这根本说不通。这就好像，如果有人实实在在地深深伤害了你，
why, like, why is it logical for you to be like? Why do you expect them to have the answer? They're the ones who hurt you. Yeah, yeah. But for the person who asks this question, I'd say probably don't do it. Or if you do take makes advice. It's like clear expectation.
为什么……为什么你还会觉得去找他们是合乎逻辑的呢？为什么你指望他们能给你答案？他们才是那个伤害了你的人。对，对。但对于提出这个问题的这个人，我的建议是：最好别去。或者如果你一定要去，就采纳梅克的建议。明确设定好预期。
And have somewhere to go. Yeah. Look a spa day. A good, yeah, mutual meeting place. A spa day. Did you say? No, not with the person. Like afterwards.
并且找个有地方可去的时间。对。比如安排一个水疗日。一个好……对，一个中立的会面地点。水疗日。你刚才说的是什么？不，不是跟那个人一起。是谈话结束之后。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. You actually get couples massages. I talk about it. Yeah, neutral meeting place is good. Like coffee, coffee place is fantastic. In public. It's weird if they cry.
对，对，对。其实你可以去做个双人按摩。我正想说这个呢。对，中立的会面地点挺好的。比如咖啡馆，咖啡馆就非常棒。在公共场合。如果他们哭了会很尴尬。
Yeah, yeah. True, true. My God, you guys are brutal at this. What does she need some tears? I don't know. Can I ask the next question? Yeah, yeah, do it, do it. Wait, from your brain or from the sheet?
对，对。真的，真的。天哪，你们在这事上可真够残忍的。难道她不需要哭一哭宣泄一下吗？我不知道。我能问下一个问题吗？对，对，问吧，问吧。等等，你是从脑子里想的还是从纸上挑的？
I don't remember them. Go for it. Okay. Like, if you can ask one as well, if you, we all can oh here's a really good one okay in your ex
我不记得了。问吧。好的。比如，如果你也想问一个的话，如果你……我们都可以——哦，这里有一个非常好的！好吧，在你的前任……
oh no I feel like I want to do that one later okay I'm in a situation ship with this guy who won't commit what should I do I think I love him ooh I have no advice to offer on this
哦不，我觉得我想把那个留到后面再问。好吧。我和一个不肯许下承诺的家伙处于“友达以上恋人未满”的状态，我该怎么办？我觉得我爱上他了。噢！我对此给不出任何建议。
okay hold on can you read it again yeah let me find it I'm in a situation ship with this guy who won't commit yeah what should I do I think I love him
好的，等等，你能再读一遍吗？行，让我找找。我和一个不肯许下承诺的家伙处于“友达以上恋人未满”的状态，对，我该怎么办？我觉得我爱上他了。
red flag dump hands Yeah, I think... Oh, that's, that's... Yeah, yeah. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. No, that's so sad, though. I'm sorry.
红牌警告，直接甩掉！对，我觉得……哦，这个，这个……对，对。开玩笑的。我开玩笑的。不，不过这真的太惨了，抱歉。
I have been in so many situationships. I feel like... You see, yeah, I think you're only one. Maybe you a little bit. We've been in a situation ship? Do you know what this is? If you, yeah, I know what a situation is. Yeah, yeah.
我经历过太多次这种暧昧不清的关系了。我觉得……你看，对，我觉得你只经历过一次。也许你稍微有过一点？我们经历过这种暧昧关系吗？你知道这是什么吗？如果你……对，我知道什么是暧昧。对，对。
It's like you're not in a relationship, but you're doing. No, a few small ones, yeah, but nothing crazy. Yeah. But it's, yeah, it's, it's, it's really tough because I think it depends on what the parameters are. And I think, the parameters are almost always, hey, I'm not looking to get into a relationship. I don't want to commit.
就好像你们不是在谈恋爱，但你们在做……没有，有过几次小的，对，但没什么疯狂的。对。但，对，这真的很难，因为我觉得这取决于你们关系的界限是什么。而我认为，这种关系的界限几乎总是：“嘿，我不想谈恋爱，我不想承诺。”
But then they tease you with it. Spending time with you sort of thing. Yeah, yeah, exactly. I think, I actually agree. I think that you need to set up really clear boundaries about what you're looking for. And if it's not the same thing, they are not going to change their mind.
但他们又会用这个来撩你。比如花时间陪你之类的事。对，对，完全是这样。我觉得，我其实很赞同。我认为你需要为自己所追求的东西设定非常清晰的界限。如果你们的目标不一致，他们是不会改变主意的。
Yeah. They're not going to change their mind. They're not going to fall in love with you. Or even if they do, like the situations that I've seen where they do change their mind later on, it becomes this constant, like, resentment of like, I didn't want to be in a relationship and I'm like in this relationship because you wanted me to do this.
对。他们不会改变主意的。他们不会爱上你的。或者就算他们真的爱上了——比如我见过的那些后来改变主意的案例——最后也会变成一种不断滋生的怨恨：“我本来不想谈恋爱的，现在落得这个地步全是因为你想让我这么做。”
And it's this weird. Like I just, oh, yuck. Yeah, no, that's a good point. That's a good point. I think, um, yeah, I think it's important to like, I guess, be open with how you feel, but then not to pressure them into anything. Yeah. Because the boundaries are probably already set.
这就变得很诡异。就像我——哦，真让人反感。对，没错，这很有道理。这确实是个好点子。我觉得，嗯……对，我觉得坦诚表达自己的感受很重要，但同时也不要逼迫他们做任何决定。对。因为界限可能已经划定好了。
Just good communication. Yeah, that being said, it sounds like they're probably already talked about this. Yeah. Maybe have been shut down, which. Well, the other thing, which I always say come up. is people so like what kind of what you were saying gem about like it's someone like they say they don't want a relationship but then they kind of indicate that they do and then they don't and then they do and then they don't and then so you get into this situation where you're like oh
只要好好沟通就行。对。话虽如此，听起来他们可能已经讨论过这个了。对。也许已经被拒绝了，这……嗯，另一件事，我经常看到这种情况发生——
well they will because they've said that they might or they said they could and it's just like sort of and again it builds shaky foundations right it really does like they don't know what they want I think is what you take out of that and that's not a bad thing it's genuinely they don't know whether they want a relationship or not. And if you know that that's what you want, well then you have different expectations. Yeah, so right. Yeah, exactly. And I think if they're not there and they're not on the same page as
人们会……就像你刚才说的，杰姆，当有个人说他们不想谈恋爱，但他们又表现得好像其实想谈，接着一会儿说想一会儿说不想，反反复复，然后你就陷入了这样一种处境：你会想：“哦，好吧，他们最终会愿意的，因为他们说过他们可能会，或者说过他们可以。”这就像是……而且这再次说明，这种关系的基础是不稳固的，对吧？确实如此。这就好像他们自己都不知道自己想要什么，我觉得这就是你能从中得出的结论。这并不是什么坏事，他们是真的不知道自己到底想不想谈恋爱。如果你很清楚自己想要什么，那你自然会有不同的期望。对，没错。对，完全是这样。而且我觉得如果他们还没准备好，并且和不在同一个频道上……
you and they don't want to commit to anything, you just, like, as sad as it is and as terrible as it will be, you have to get out of that because otherwise you'll be, you're trapped in a situation where you're intimate with someone that you love, that you know, doesn't love you back. And that sucks. I feel really, I feel really bad for this,
你和他们不想对任何事情作出承诺，你只是，就像，尽管这很令人难过，而且会有多糟糕，你都必须摆脱那种情况，因为否则你会被困在一个局里，你和你爱的人很亲密，而你知道，对方并不爱你。这真的很逊。我真的觉得，我真的为这个感到很糟糕，
Obviously I know who this person is, but I feel, because I, like, I, and I'm not trying to be like, I feel really bad for you. Yeah. Because I feel like that's weird. But, like, I think the other important thing to realize is that, like, if they wanted to, they would. If they wanted to be in a relationship with you, they would be in a relationship with you. Yeah. And it has absolutely nothing to do with you. Yeah.
显然我知道这个人是谁，但我感觉，因为我，就像，我，我不是想装作，我真的为你感到难过。是啊。因为我觉得这很奇怪。但是，就像，我认为另一个要意识到的重要事情是，如果他们愿意，他们就会这么做。如果他们想和你谈恋爱，他们就会和你谈恋爱。是啊。而且这和你绝对没有关系。是啊。
Yeah. If they aren't ready. And to be honest, they're going to fucking probably regret it. Like, if you have this, like, very beautiful feeling for them that is, like, really precious and pure. and you have to see the best parts of someone else to feel that way. And they're saying no, take that and give it to someone who really deserves it. And I bet you, I bet you some good money that in a few months, a few years' time, that person's going to still be thinking about you being like, damn.
是啊。如果他们还没准备好。老实说，他们他妈的可能会后悔。就像，如果你对他们有这种，非常美好的感觉，这是真的非常珍贵和纯洁的。而且你必须看到别人最好的一面才会有这种感觉。而他们在拒绝，那就把那份心意拿走，给真正配得上它的人。我敢打赌，我敢用好钱打赌，在几个月、几年后，那个人依然会想起你，心里会想：天哪。
Yeah. Like that person really cared about me and I just like didn't. That sounds a bit toxic. Also, like, you know. But move on because you won't find that person that you'll be able to, you know, share that love with until you move on from this person. who clearly doesn't want that right now. Yeah. And it ends up hurting you.
是啊。就像那个人曾经真的很在乎我，而我却只是……这听起来有点毒。而且，就像，你知道的。但继续向前看吧，因为在你走出这个人之前，你不会找到那个能让你去分享那种爱的人。而这个人现在显然不想要这个。是啊。最后这会伤害到你。
Yeah, totally. It's so much to say. It's sort of like you have to do some like damage control for yourself. And like maybe if you're a person who just gets over those kinds of things really quickly and just moves on with their lives, okay, fair like full steam ahead. Like do whatever you want. Like live your life. Like get some good creative story inspiration.
完全是这样。有很多话要说。这就好像你得为自己做一些损害控制。而且，可能如果你是一个能很快放下那种事情并继续生活的人，好吧，那也行，那就全速前进吧。就像做你想做的事。就像过你自己的生活。就像寻找一些好的创意故事灵感。
Yeah. But I think like you have to sort of be like, okay, well, this person is flip-flopping. even if they do decide that they do want a relationship somewhere down the track, this whole period where like you've been chasing them sets up this weird power dynamic in your relationship, which is just going to persist for the duration of the relationship. And you're just like setting yourself up for a crap situation, regardless of whether it goes, if it turns into a relationship or not. And that's just really sad.
是啊。但我认为你得有点像是，好吧，这个人现在反复无常。即使他们过了一段时间后最终决定他们确实想要恋爱，你一直在追逐他们的这段时期，也会在你们的关系中建立起一种奇怪的权力动态，这种动态会在你们恋爱的整个过程中一直持续下去。无论最终能否发展成恋爱关系，你其实都是在为自己设下一个糟糕的处境。这真的很让人难过。
That's so true. And it's like there are people who are not like that out there in the world that would be so much better and more lovely and wonderful. Yeah. And we'd appreciate you. Yeah. Because you deserve better. You deserve much better than that.
真的。这就好比世界上还有很多不是那样的人，他们会好得多、可爱得多、美妙得多。是啊。并且会欣赏你。是啊。因为你值得更好的。你值得比那好得多。
Oh, yeah. And it's, although they might not have necessarily done anything wrong, you deserve to be in a better situation. Totally. That's so true. And like I'm sorry that you're in that situation
哦，对。而且，尽管他们不一定做错了什么，但你确实值得拥有更好的处境。完全同意。真的。而且我很抱歉你现在处于那种状况中，
because I like know what that feels like and it really, really sucks. And you're just sitting there being like, is this not enough? And you are enough for the right person. And this person obviously isn't the right person. Yeah.
因为我懂那种感觉，这真的、真的很糟糕。而你只能坐在那里想：这还不够吗？对于对的人来说，你是足够的。而这个人显然不是对的人。是啊。
Well, they're not enough for you. Yeah, they're not enough for you. Your expectations are higher than what they want. It's like the exact opposite is they're not meeting your expectations. Yeah, like you're actually the one. Yeah, you're so right. Like, it's not like, oh my God, like I'm not good enough for them. It's like, no, like if they're not going to meet you.
嗯，是他们对你来说还不够。是啊，他们对你来说还不够。你的期望比他们想要的要高。这就好比完全相反的情况，是他们没有达到你的期望。是啊，就好像实际上是你……是啊，你说得太对了。就像，并不是说，天哪，我配不上他们。而是，不，如果他们达不到你的要求。
And obviously, it's not like they're a demon, they're a devil, they're a villain. Like, if they've set up clear expectations and somehow you've kind of lost your way a little bit, it is kind of your responsibility to be like, okay, well, they were really open with me about what they wanted. If they were open with you. And I think it's a different question if they were gaslighty and glorious, which I know you hate the word gaslighting. I know, but in the situation it kind of is like that.
很显然，他们不是什么恶魔、魔鬼或坏人。如果他们明确表达了期望，而你不知怎么的有点迷失了方向，那么说“好吧，他们对我想要什么真的很坦诚”就是你自己的责任。如果他们对你很坦诚的话。而且我认为，如果他们有煤气灯效应（PUA）和浮夸的表现，那就是另一个问题了——我知道你讨厌“煤气灯”这个词。我知道，但在这种情况下确实有点像那样。
I hope that's enough. Good luck. Yeah, Jack wants to move to a new question. Yeah, I love it. I love it. This is so fun. Yeah, are you liking it? What's the next question, Jack?
希望这些够了。祝你好运。是啊，杰克想进入下一个问题。是啊，我喜欢。我喜欢。这太有趣了。是啊，你喜欢吗？下一个问题是什么，杰克？
The next one we could do. Okay, we got, okay, here we go. This is a friendship one. Yeah. Oh, spice it up. I feel like I've lost a lot of friends and drifted from people during lockdown. I feel like people hate me and don't want to be around me. How do I make new friends?
下一个我们可以做。好的，我们有，好的，我们来吧。这是一个关于友谊的问题。是啊。哦，来点刺激的。我觉得在封城期间我失去了很多朋友，和大家疏远了。我觉得人们讨厌我，不想和我在一起。我该怎么交新朋友？
Can I read it? Yeah. Aw. So, okay, I think there's kind of, it's, it feels like a two-parter. Yeah. It feels like that they're, you feel, you feel very disconnected from your current friends and you feel like you've drifted from them and maybe you feel like you've done something to do. that or partly responsible and then there's how do I make new friends yeah yeah and or regend, I think jem is one of the best people I know making new friends.
我能读一下吗？是啊。噢。所以，好吧，我觉得这有点像，这感觉像是一个分两部分的问题。是啊。感觉好像是，你觉得，你和你现有的朋友非常疏离，你觉得你和他们疏远了，也许你觉得自己做了什么导致了这一点，或者负有一部分责任，然后就是“我该怎么交新朋友”。是啊，杰姆，我认为杰姆是我认识的交新朋友最厉害的人之一。
Wow big calls so we got you covered well I think if you think that people hate you you probably shouldn't be around them yeah well this is what I was going to say is like because I think I've had a similar experience with this where I sort of felt like I lost touch with a lot of people and tried to sort of rekindle those friendships and was like, I feel like these people hate me. And I think if you interrogate that feeling a little bit more and you're like, okay, well, maybe I actually, they don't hate me. Maybe I'm insecure about this friendship because it doesn't feel quite right. And I think sort of like interrogating that a little bit more and like sort of thinking about,
哇，这评价可真高。那我们帮你搞定。嗯，我想如果你觉得人们讨厌你，你可能就不应该和他们在一起。是啊，好吧，我本来要说的是，因为我想我也有过类似的经历，我曾觉得自己和很多人失去了联系，并试图重燃那些友谊，然后就想：“我觉得这些人讨厌我。”我想如果你再深入审视一下这种感觉，然后想：“好吧，也许实际上，他们并不是讨厌我。也许我对这段友谊感到没有安全感，因为它感觉不太对劲。”我觉得稍微再审视一下那种感觉，然后思考……
well, why is it that I feel this way and like what is communicating that feeling to me? And sometimes I found like, I'm like, you know, I don't know, like to my. my mom and sort of like, oh, someone so hates me. And she's like, why do you think that? And I was like, I don't know. Like, I just feel like that today. Yeah. I'm like, oh, like, well, actually, I think that they don't like me because they said this thing
嗯，为什么我会这样觉得，是什么在向我传达这种感觉？有时我发现，我会对……对妈妈说：“哦，某某讨厌我。”她就会问：“你为什么这么觉得？”然后我说：“我不知道。我今天就是这种感觉。”是啊。然后我说：“哦，嗯，其实，我觉得他们不喜欢我，是因为他们说了这样一句话……”
that I just really hate or. And then I'm like, okay, well, I don't, I don't want that friendship anymore. Yeah. Because, you know, that whatever they're doing that makes me feel like I hate them is, yeah. And I think, yeah, use it as a growth opportunity. Like, clearly, clearly you didn't value your friends enough and maybe your friends didn't value you enough to stay connected during lockdown. One thing lockdown taught me was that I figured out who I really want to spend time with
我真的很讨厌。然后我就想：“好吧，我不想再维持这段友谊了。”是啊。因为，你知道，不管他们做了什么让我觉得讨厌我的事，是啊。而且我认为，是的，把它当作一个成长的契机。很明显，很明显你没有足够珍视你的朋友，也许你的朋友也没有足够珍视你，以至于在封城期间保持联系。封城教会我的一件事是，我弄清楚了在封城期间我到底想和谁一起度过时光，
during lockdown and used it as an opportunity to be like, well, maybe I can have better friends. That sounds kind of toxic. Quality over quantity. But like better friends and let's make some new friends and develop new connections. Yeah. And set your intentions really clearly with what you want out of your new friends and then go for it. Yeah.
并把它当成一个机会去想：嗯，也许我可以拥有更好的朋友。这听起来有点毒。宁缺毋滥。但就像更好的朋友，让我们去交一些新朋友，建立新的联系。是啊。并且非常明确地设定你对新朋友的期望，然后去追求它们。是啊。
And also, like, so this is a quote that like Sam, my friend Sam, friend of the show. I love a good show. Friend of the show. My beautiful friend Sam in Melbourne, he has said to me before, and it's kind of, I've said it on the podcast before, like if you're not losing friends, you're not growing. Yeah. And I do think that's really true because there was also that saying people in your life for a reason
还有，就像，这是我朋友萨姆的一句名言，秀的朋友萨姆。我喜欢一个好节目。秀的朋友。我在墨尔本的美丽朋友萨姆以前对我说过，我也在播客里说过，如果你没有失去朋友，你就在停止成长。是啊。而且我真的觉得这很有道理，因为以前也有过那种说法：生命中的人出现都是有原因的，
a season or a lifetime. And I think that it's important to be like, firstly, it might not be that they hate you. it might just be that you are a bit socially anxious because you haven't seen people for a while. And in that case, it's always better just to be like, what's up? Let's talk about it. And like, I never do this. But I wish that I did. So there's my advice.
要么是一阵子，要么是一辈子。我认为重要的一点是：首先，可能不是他们讨厌你，而可能只是因为你有点社交焦虑，因为你有一段时间没见到人了。在这种情况下，最好还是说：“最近怎么样？我们聊聊吧。”而且，我从来不这么做。但我希望我这么做了。所以这就是我的建议。
And if they, like Meg was saying, if they're giving you the eke or making you feel like you're not appreciated, it's better to be like alone than to be in the company of people who make you feel lonely. Yeah. Like, I really, I think that is so important. Yeah. sometimes you lose friends and sometimes you lose a lot of friends all at once and it just means you have so much more opportunity
如果他们像梅格所说的那样，让你感到不舒服，或者让你觉得没有被感激，那么宁愿独自一人，也不要和那些让你感到孤独的人在一起。是啊。就像，我真的，我觉得这太重要了。是啊。有时你会失去朋友，有时你会一下子失去很多朋友，这意味着你有更多机会
to put yourself in situations where you can make like I had this where I had like a mass exodus almost and then I just was like this is like a really good sign that I need to like I've changed these people have changed in their own ways we haven't changed in the same direction it's time to find people who suit this part of me now this new version of my life
把自己置于能结交新朋友的环境中——我有过这样的经历，当时几乎经历了一场大规模的人员流失，然后我当时就想：“这真是一个很好的迹象，表明我需要……我已经变了，这些人以他们自己的方式变了，我们没有朝着同一个方向改变，是时候去找那些适合我人生现在这个阶段、这个新版本的人了。”
and I think I think it's like in your 20s you're friends with people who you either work with, who you know from high school and university, or who you have shared hobbies and experiences with. Or who you live with, yeah. And so I think it's getting into a shared experience or a shared hobby is a fantastic way to do it. So like find your hobby. It's really, you'll make some really good friends.
而且我觉得，在你的20多岁时，你交的朋友要么是和你一起工作的人，要么是你在高中和大学认识的人，要么是与你有共同爱好和经历的人。或者和你住在一起的人，是啊。所以我觉得，融入一种共同的经历或共同的爱好是做到这一点的绝佳方法。所以去找你的爱好吧。真的，你会结交一些非常棒的朋友。
Yeah. I do theater a bit. I've made some fantastic friends through that. And it's really, really special, even if you won't know them for your whole life. you will know them for like a really interesting and fun set time. Yeah. And it makes you feel less only. It makes you feel staying.
是啊。我偶尔演演戏剧。我通过这个结交了一些非常棒的朋友。而且这真的、真的很特别，即使你不会一辈子都认识他们，但在一套非常有趣和好玩的固定时间里，你会认识他们。是啊。这会让你觉得不那么孤独。这会让你觉得……
Yeah. Yeah. And would you say similar things? Yeah, yeah, definitely. And I think it's like it's good once you start developing most separate circles of friends. Because it's also like you're not going to be stoked with every single one of your friends at every single point in time.
是啊。你会说类似的话吗？是的，是的，绝对会。而且我觉得，一旦你开始发展出几个人际圈子，这其实挺好的。因为这也是为了说明，你不可能在每个时间点都对你的每一个朋友都感到极其满意。
Oh, yeah. Like I think, you need some space to move around. And I was a bit of, I was a bit weird in first year. I'm sure. Yeah, so was I've heard. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You're all a bit weird. Yeah, no, I think the other thing that I will say, though, is that just because you've lost
哦，是的。我觉得，你需要一些空间来四处走动。我大一的时候有点……有点古怪。我确信。是啊，我听说我也是。是啊，是啊，是啊。你们都有点古怪。是啊，不，不过我要说的另一件事是，仅仅因为你在封城期间失去了联系，并不必然意味着你就不应该再和那些人做朋友了，因为我想我肯定做过这种事。比如，我，就像，去年我回家过封城时，我可能几个月都不和别人说话。那并不是因为我不想再和那些人做朋友了。而是有点像，有些人很擅长发短信、保持联系和……
touch during lockdown doesn't inherently mean that you shouldn't be friends with those people anymore because I think I've certainly done this. Like, I, like, probably when I went home for lockdown last year, I didn't talk to people for like months at a time. And that wasn't a product of, you know, the fact that I didn't want to be friends with those people anymore. It's sort of like, there are some people who are. really good at texting and staying in touch and
FaceTime，而另一些人则不太适合这种方式，或者你知道，这感觉，你知道，我不知道，我认为这也是，不过你也应该试着去解决这个问题，我认为这是另一件需要做的事，也就是去想：好吧，我有一段时间没和别人说话了，现在我对这感到很糟糕，
FaceTiming and then there are people who that doesn't quite work for them or you know it feels you know I don't know and I think that's you know but you also should try and work on that I think is something that is the other thing is sort of being like okay well I didn't talk to people for an extended period of time that's now I'm feeling crap about that
所以下次如果再发生封城，或者你去海外度假，开始一份新工作，或者搬到一个新城市，是啊，那是你需要多推自己一把的事情，而且我会说，这次在封城期间，我确实做出了更多努力。是啊，是啊。而且我想你会经历一次，然后就会想：
so next time when this if you know there's a lockdown again or you go on an overseas holiday you start a new job or you move cities yeah that's something to kind of push a little bit more and I would say that this time during lockdown I've made a bit more of an effort. Yeah, yeah. And I think you sort of, you go through it once and you're like,
哦，好吧，你知道，我本可以把这样那样的事情做得更好。然后你会想：不，不，那些人确实是。有些朋友我在封城期间没保持联系，但我真的很想和他们保持联系。那就联系他们，就直接说。是啊，是啊。如果他们是好朋友，会理解的，对吧？是啊。
oh, well, you know, I could have done X, Y, Z better. And you're like, you know, no, those, these really are people. There are friends that I didn't stay in touch with in lockdown who I really do want to stay in touch with. And just reach out, just be like. Yeah, yeah. And if they're good friends, I'll understand, right? Yeah.
而且我也觉得大家都在经历各自的糟心事。是啊，在封城期间。在封城期间。比如，我在封城期间失去了爷爷，而且还发生了其他事情。当时就觉得，这并不是对那些我没有保持联系的人的某种反映。更像是，我实在是应接不暇。是啊。
And also I think that people are going through their own shit. Yeah, during lockdown. During lockdown. Like, I lost my granddad during lockdown and, like, had other things happen. And it was like, it's not a really. reflection on the people I didn't keep in touch with. It's more of like, I'm just overwhelmed. Yeah.
就好像，我只是做不到像以前那样。就像我没有那么多空间和地方去充电。是啊，我有我的房子。不过，梅格，你确实做得好得多。我记得第一次封城时，你简直宅得不行。是啊。她真的很认真地执行了居家令。从好的方面来说。
And it's like, I just can't do the same. Like, I don't have as much space and places to go to recharge. Yeah, I have my house. But, Meg, you did do a much better job. I remember when first lockdown, you hermitted hard. Yeah. She really took the order very seriously. In a good way.
然后第二次封城时，你处理得真的很好。是啊，是啊。我觉得这就好比是：好吧，给别人打电话对我来说感觉有点奇怪。所以我就会想：好吧，这次我可以去散步，这样能见到人。是啊，我可以。我们进行了FaceTime。是啊，是啊，玩游戏，然后，做那种事。我发现有趣得多。
And then this lockdown, you were like really good about it. Yeah, yeah. I think it's sort of being like, okay, well, calling people feels a little bit weird for me. So I'm like, okay, well, this time I could go and walk so people. Yeah, I could. We did FaceTime. Yeah, yeah, play games and like, do, like, you know, that sort of thing. I found a lot more fun.
所以我觉得，是的，这是一个学习的过程。是啊。听起来有点尴尬，但确实是。是啊。我们这里还有另一个问题。其实是一个陈述。里面没有任何问题。我男友比我更喜欢攀岩。
So I think it's sort of, yeah, it's a learning experience. Yeah. It's kind of cringe, but yeah. Yeah. We got another question here. It's actually a statement. There's no question involved. My boyfriend likes rock climbing more than me.
就是这样。是啊，就是这样。我想，我想，亲爱的，你得成为他世界里的“布”。我觉得自己非常有建议者的智慧。你得做能战胜“石头”的“布”。我觉得你得加把劲了。不。哦，话说回来，我知道是谁写的，杰克。
That's it. Yeah, that's it. I think, I think, honey, you've got to be the paper in his world. I'm feeling very advice, Sage. You've got to be the paper that beats the rocks. I think you've got to step it up. No. Oh, again, I know who wrote this, Jack.
哦，很糟糕吗？不，挺好的。谁写的？跟他在现实中玩石头剪刀布。是啊。如果你出布，他就得停止去攀岩。是啊。就像，你知道吗？
Oh, is it bad? No, it's fine. Who wrote it? Places this paper rock with him. Yeah. And if you get paper, he has to stop going, rock. Yeah. Just like, you know what?
另外，你男友有爱好是件好事。是啊。他有爱好是件好事。而且还是项锻炼。哦。真的，真的，因为我把玩游戏当成爱好，是啊。你玩电子游戏？不，我知道，那就是，所以我才这么说，然后我们看到你时，就像是……我会问：“你刚刚哭过吗？”然后你会说：
Also, it's good that your boyfriend has a hobby. Yeah. It's good that he has a hobby. And that it's an exercise. Oh. True. true because I play games as a hobby yeah you play video games no I know that's that's so I'm saying and then we see you and it's like I'm like have you been crying and you're like
“没有，我只是在玩电子游戏。”是啊，情况可能会更糟，攀岩是个很酷的爱好。是啊，是啊。而且我也觉得男生很不擅长——这只是一个广泛的概括，一个一概而论的概括——但年轻男生真的很不擅长建立健康的作息和健康的生活方式，不擅长去想：好吧，当我连续坐着玩八个小时电子游戏时，这让我感觉有点恶心，而且我从来、从来不会感觉良好。
no I've just been playing video yeah it could be it could be worse rock climbing is a cool hobby yeah yeah and I also think men are really bad and just this is a broad generalization a sweeping generalization but young men are really bad at like building healthy routines and healthy lifestyles and being like okay well when I sit and play video games for eight hours straight that makes me feel kind of gross and like I never never feel good
不，不，你不会的，但你挺擅长去健身房之类的地方，这就好比是，是啊，是啊，去演你的戏剧，你知道的，去上班，并拥有一个能给你很多空间去成长、做其他事情、保持思维活跃的作息，你知道的，所以我觉得有个爱好是件好事。
no no you don't but you're quite good with like going to the gym and stuff like that and it's about like yeah yeah and doing your theatre and like you know it's going to work and having like a routine that gives you lots of space to grow and do other things and keep stimulated and you know and so I feel like a hobby is good
是啊，但如果他喜欢攀岩胜过喜欢你……是啊，你知道的，关系是随着时间推移而发展的。也许你可以陪他去攀岩。或者至少去岩壁那儿陪陪他。是啊。他们会一起去攀岩吗？
yeah but if he likes rock climbing more than he likes you Yeah You know, relationships grow over time Maybe go rock climbing with him Or at least just hang out With him at the rocks Yeah Do they go rock climbing together?
我不能泄露关于这个人的个人信息。公平，公平，公平。但他们没有。所以……但我觉得，如果你俩有各自独立的生活，其实也没关系。
I can't divulge personal information About this person Fair, fair, fair But they don't So But I feel like Also, it's okay if you have two separate If you have separate lives
那真的很好。是啊，真的。其实真的很好。因为你可以利用那个空间去想：好吧，我要去爬岩石之类的事情，思考一下我的感受。是啊，是啊。然后只是减压，然后，是啊，共度优质时光。还有，岩石是没有脉搏的。是啊，那很重要，那是个文身。
That's really good Yeah, true It's actually really good Because you can use that A space to be like Okay well I'm gonna go and climb rocks and things and think about my feelings yeah yeah and just decompress um and then yeah spend quality time together also rocks don't have a pulse yeah that's that's important that's a tattoo
是啊，是啊，我不知道，是啊，岩石没有脉搏，嗯，岩石没有脉搏，你是有脉搏的，把这个写在你的墙上。是啊，岩石没有肯定。是啊，岩石没有脉搏，我有脉搏。另外，这非常小众，但这也让送礼物变得非常简单。哦，太随性了。直接送他一块石头。是啊。去爬这个吧。
yeah yeah i don't know yeah rocks rocks don't have a pulse um rocks don't have a pulse you have a pulse write that on your wall yeah rocks don't have affirmation yeah rocks don't have a pulse i have a pulse Also, this is super niche, but it also makes gifting really easy. Oh, random. Just give them a rock. Yeah. Clive this. Climb this fucker.
是啊，不过攀岩要买的东西也太多了吧？小手套之类的东西。是啊，是啊。还有绳子。我喜欢那种装着镁粉的小袋子。是啊。你们显然……我有一张小脸。
Yeah, but there's so much stuff to get around rock climb, isn't there? Little gloves and things. Yeah, yeah. You ropes. I love the little pouches with the chalk in them. Yeah. You guys obviously. I have a little face.
手套。小鞋子。是啊，鞋子挺酷的。送礼物的绝佳选择。是啊。还有能量棒，供他们……是啊。攀岩后吃。
Gloves. Little shoes. Yeah, the shoes are cool. It's great gifting. Yeah. Yeah, protein bars for when they... Yeah. After the rocks.
是啊。或者攀岩中途吃。是啊。攀岩中途。这里有太多东西可以展开了。而且我很高兴我们展开了。攀岩中途。杰克，你一直在过这些问题。
Yeah. Or mid rock. Yeah. Or mid rock. There's so much to unpack here. And I'm glad we have. Mid rock. Jack, you're moving through these questions.
我是说，是的，我不知道。我只是喜欢。那个问题的结论是什么？我们的结论是……嗯，开始时是建议做打败石头的布。这只是……但我们最后是以什么收尾的？是啊。
I mean, yeah, I don't know. I just like it. What was that conclusion on that one? Our conclusion is... Well, it started with be the paper to the rock. And it's just... But what are we ending on? Yeah.
我觉得只要他不睡在岩石上，或者，我不知道，跟岩石睡觉。是啊。哦，对。那对他的健康可不好。我是说，你知道是谁写的，
I feel like as long as he's not like sleeping on the rocks or like, I don't know, sleeping with the rocks. Yeah. Oh, yeah. That would be bad for him. Is it, I mean, you know who wrote,
这真的是个真正的担忧吗？我觉得是的。好吧，好吧。哦，不。好吧，是的。我觉得算是一半半吧。好吧，嗯，只要他不，
is it a genuine concern? I think it is. Okay, okay. Oh, no. Okay, yeah. I think it's semi. Okay, well, yeah, as long as he's not,
跟岩石胡搞。我想，我想，应该就没事了。是啊，是啊，我觉得这可能是一回事。围绕岩石设定一些界限，规定他能去攀岩多少次。是啊，还有多少……
fooling around with the rocks. I think, I think, it should be right. Yeah, yeah, I think it could be a thing. It's set boundaries around the rocks about how much he can go rock climbing. Yeah, and how much,
是啊，花多少时间。他应该来“攀爬”你才对。是啊，是啊，说得好。嗯，对，因为你可不想落入那种阶段：他成了那种跟岩石睡觉、搭帐篷的人。哦，那个，好吧，我很抱歉。因为那有点过头了。而且那太危险了。
Yeah, how much time. He should be climbing you instead. Yeah, yeah, well put. Well, yeah, because you don't want to get into a stage where he's one of those people that are sleeping with the rocks where they pitch. Hold's a tent. Oh, that, okay, I'm sorry. Because that's a bit much. And that's just dangerous.
当他在做那种事时，你会感到害怕。还有，如果你觉得他喜欢石头胜过喜欢你，你应该去看看那部关于那个叫亚历克斯·霍尔诺德的家伙的纪录片。他在片中就像是……他有这样一个漂亮的女朋友，他对她说：“我爱你，我想和你组建家庭。”然后他说：“我想在不使用安全带的情况下登顶世界上最高的山峰之一，对不起，宝贝，如果我死了的话。”而他真的去做了。
It's scary for you when he's doing that. Also, if you think that he likes rocks more than he likes you, you should watch that documentary with that Alex Holland guy. where he like he like has this beautiful girlfriend he's like I love you I want to start a family with you and he's like I want to summit one of the tallest mountains in the world without using a harness sorry baby if I die and he does it
你看，那有点过分了，对吧？是啊。那会很伤心。那是另一个故事了。你可不想发展到那种地步，就是……他成了那种石头人。是啊。就像一个……
See that's a bit much right Yeah that would be sad That's a different story You don't want to get to that point where Yeah He's one of those rock people Yeah Just like a
我只是去弄那些《冰雪奇缘》里的小岩石人。你知道那多可爱吗？是啊，那很可爱。你的宝宝们以后就会长得像那些小岩石人。我不知道。他的私生子。是啊。
I'm just to get those little rock things in Frozen You know that's so cute Yeah that's cute That's what your babies will look like there's little rock things. I don't know. He's like illegitimate children. Yeah.
还有，抱歉一开始叫你亲爱的。我不是故意要摆出居高临下的姿态。我只是觉得自己很有智慧。他非常像慈母。是啊。别担心，国王。谢谢，谢谢，詹姆斯。闭嘴吧，国王。
And sorry for calling you honey at the start. I wasn't trying to be patronizing. I just felt very sage. He's very motherly. Yeah. Don't worry, King. Thanks, thanks, James. Shut up, King.
谢谢。前几天我被非正式地、实实在在地叫了“国王”。挺搞笑的。谁这么干的？就是某个人，对，是的。我最喜欢做的事——前几天我还在跟我的一个朋友说这个——我最喜欢做的事，就是去看那些当DJ的家伙的Instagram直播，然后说：“我们爱小个子国王。”是啊。我看看他们的
Thanks. I got called King ironically, unironically the other day. It was quite funny. Who did that? Just someone, yeah, it was. My favorite thing to be doing, I was telling one of my friends this the other day, my favorite thing is to go on like Instagram lives of like, guys doing like who are like DJs and be like we love a short king yeah I see what their
反应。是啊，我在TikTok上看到的，然后我也开始这么做了。是啊，我喜欢用……是啊，超级巨星。是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊，冠军。嘿，是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊，或者，肌肉男，这是你的叔叔们在打橄榄球时会用的一个经典称呼，当你开始打橄榄球时……是啊，那是我对“肌肉男”的体验。是啊，别担心，肌肉男，你宝刀未老。哦，嗯，好吧，所以我们的下一个问题，真的是一个超级大的问题。这里有很多内容要探讨。所以这个匿名的提问者说：我和女朋友分手了，但我有点想念她的妈妈。
reaction yeah I saw it on TikTok and I started doing it yeah I like using yeah superstar yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah champ hey yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah or or muscles is a classic one you get from from like from like your uncles when you when you're playing rugby start playing rugby yeah yeah yeah that was my experience with muscles yeah yeah don't worry muscles you still got it oh um okay I'm So our next question, it's a really big one. Lots to unpack here. So this anonymous question asking human said, my girlfriend and I broke up, but I miss her mom.
我很确定她妈妈也很想我。是啊。怎么办？我猜那是，我该怎么办？我想切入点是，我要推荐一首歌，叫《斯黛西的妈妈》。是啊。哦，天哪。我觉得这可能是一首很好的歌词……
Pretty sure mom misses me too. Yeah. What do? I assume that was, what should I do? I think the starting point, I'm going to recommend a song called Stacey's mom. Yeah. Oh my God. I think it might be good text to.
去看看。是啊。一个不错的，给你的一些家庭作业，一些阅读材料。是啊，是啊。或者如果你无法与她的妈妈重建联系，
to look at. Yeah. A good, there's some homework for you, some reading. Yeah, yeah. Or if you can't rebuild connections with her mom,
比如说，你知道，你，是啊，你知道，那也行。我建议你在Tinder上把年龄范围调高一点。
like say it, you know, you, yeah, you know, that's fine. I would suggest setting your age range higher on Tinder.
是啊。我觉得你会遇到很多新朋友。哦，你有很多妈妈类型的角色可以来替代旧的那一个。我也觉得，就像，你知道的，在分手时，女朋友会把妈妈“赢”走。是啊。
Yeah. I think you'll meet plenty of new friends. Oh, you have a lot of mummy figures to replace the old one. I also think that like, you know, the girlfriend gets the mom in the breakup. Yeah.
你得不到，那是她妈。是啊。那是她妈。是啊。归根结底，她爱你并没有像爱她女儿那样多。是啊，归根结底，这就是她妈，这是定局，差不多就是这样。但如果你需要熟女能量的话。
You don't get, it's her mom. Yeah. It's her mom. Yeah. At the end of the day, she didn't love you as much as she loved her daughter. Yeah, at the end of the day, it is, it is her mom and that's final, more or less. But if you need the milf energies.
是啊。因为外面有大把大把的妈妈。外面有很多妈妈，你知道的，她们有你没去约会过的女儿，或者有你没去约会过的儿子。是啊。而且我觉得，去引导那种能量，去专注于那个。是啊。是啊。别再投射了，宝贝。
Yeah. Because there's plenty of moms out there. There's plenty of moms out there that, you know, that have daughters that you didn't go out with or have sons that you didn't go out with. Yeah. And I think, channel that, hone into that. Yeah. Yeah. Stop projecting, babe.
是啊。你需要冷静一下。还有，她妈妈会想你吗？可能不会吧。所以也许你需要……老兄，我觉得，是啊，好吧，你可以找一个能给你母爱的新女朋友。
Yeah. You need to chill. also does her mom miss you probably not so maybe you need to dude i i think yeah yeah well you could just find a new girlfriend who mothers you
是啊，这是个绝妙的建议。确实如此，确实如此。是啊，是啊。去找一个带有母性能量的女朋友，这种人多的是。不过老兄，我真是个极具母性的女朋友。我也是。是啊，我本来想说，我们没法比，我们没法说什么。我是……即使是对那些我没有在谈恋爱的男生，我也很有母性。这太荒谬了。我正在教某人
yeah that's a hot tip that's true that's true that's true yeah yeah find find a girlfriend with mothery mothery energy there's plenty of them but dude i'm such a mothery girlfriend me too yeah i was gonna say we can't talk we can't say shit the queen of i'm i'm mother even the guys i'm not in a relationship with. It's ridiculous. I'm teaching someone
开车呢，就在刚才。还有什么比这更具母性能量的吗？那确实很有母性。我知道。是啊，那超越了我的妈系能量。我从来没这么父爱泛滥过。
how to fucking drive right now. What was more mummy energy than that? That's very mummy energy. I know. Yeah, that exceeds my mom energy. Yeah. I've never been that fatherly.
你从来没有当过……从你刚才管提问者叫“亲爱的”开始。是啊，那是……那是父爱吗？那是你父爱的高光时刻。亲爱的。曾有人告诉我我会是个好爸爸。
You've never been a poem. From when you called the question Ask a Honey before. Yeah, that was, was that fatherly? That was your peak fatherly. Honey. I've been told I'd be a good dad.
你绝对会是个好爸爸。我很乐意当爸爸。噢，你一定会带来超多乐趣。是啊。如果我有了孩子，你可以当他们的……不是爸爸，而是教父之类的。
You'd be such a good dad. I'd love to be a dad. Aw, you'd be so much fun. Yeah. If I've had kids, you can be there like, not their dad but like the godfather
好吧，好吧，教父。好吧，对于任何正在收听、怀念前任爸爸的播客听众来说，你们有一个……他是海娜的“爹地”。随时可以来寻求建议，
okay okay godfather yeah well for any pod listeners who are looking who we're missing their ex's dad you have a oh he's daddy to henna feel free to give advice
或者玩乐高。我喜欢和孩子们一起玩。我是的，我真的喜欢。我就是喜欢和我的小表亲们一起玩，他们还是小孩子，跟他们在一起玩非常有意思而且很可爱。真的超可爱，
or play Lego I love with the kids I do I do like I just love playing with my little cousins that are kids they're so fun to hang out with and cute it's really cute
而且我也想……我热衷于去做我小时候做过的所有那些小孩子的玩意儿。我爸去哪了。是啊，这就是你唯一的动机，你想去读……嗯，就像，向他们介绍所有这些酷炫的东西，比如《星球大战》。是啊，我怎么知道你会说《星球大战》？是啊，还有乐高，还有蝙蝠侠和星际电子游戏。所有的漫威电影。我太热衷了。那一定会非常有趣。梅格，你想要小小梅格吗？是啊，我想是的。小凯文。我本来想说“梅格仔”。大凯文。哦，“梅格仔”。哦，“梅格仔”。哦，
and I want to I'm keen to do all the kid things that I did when I was a kid one of my dad go. Yeah, that's the only reason you want to, you want to read the well, like, introducing them to all this cool stuff like Star Wars. Yeah, how do I know you were going to say Star Wars? Yeah, and Lego and like Batman and Star video games. All the Marvel movies. I'm so keen. That would be really fun. Meg, do you want little Meggies? Yeah, I think so. Little Kevin's. I was going to say Meglings. Big Kev. Oh, Meglings. Oh, Meglings. Oh,
“梅格仔”。哦，那太可爱了。这有点吓人。我喜欢这样。哦，天哪，想象一下一个迷你梅格在奔跑。顺着这个大厅。就像，想象一下梅格，就像缩水了一样，在商场里奔跑。你看，我不知道这到底是有史以来最吓人的事情，还是……或者像，但我有这种，这种蛮可爱的孩子。我觉得，吓人。哦，天哪，你以前太吓人了。
Meglings. Oh, that's so cute. It's kind of scary. I love that. Oh, my God, imagine a tiny Megg running. down this whole. Like, imagine Meg, like shrunk, running down the more. See, I don't know whether that's the most terrifying thing ever. Or, like, but I have this, like, a kind of cute kid. I feel like, terrifying. Oh, my God, you were so terrifying.
就像在跑，踩着乱蓬蓬的头发到处小跑。不，电脑里的照片才最搞笑。是啊。你们拿到……哦，天哪。老兄，你会想要一个小小梅格吗？我每天都在努力工作。我很沮丧。这感觉就像是……就像，每天都在为了生计奔波。
Like, running down, trotting all over the face with sticking hair. No, the computer pictures the funniest. Yeah. You guys got, oh, my God. Dude, would you want to be, would you want a little Meglings? I'm working every day. I'm depressed. What is this like, um, it's like, um, it's like, every day we're hustling.
或者就像，全凭动力，全凭力量，我们保持饥饿。那是小时候的梅格。哦，天哪。我当时就像是在组织一场完整的演出，有门票，由我来唱《我是芭比娃娃》。委托班里的孩子们……你，你做过这个吗？因为我做过……你有没有给父母演过小短剧和小表演？
Or like, it's about drive. about power and we stay hungry. That was Meg when she was a kid. Oh my God. I was like me organizing an entire like performance with tickets for me to sing I'm a Barbie girl. Commissioning like children in my classes. Did you, did you do this? Because I did like did you do little plays and performances to your parents?
我把它提升到了一个新的高度。就像我离开学前班的教室，邀请了整个学校。我做了门票。太棒了。全校都来看我表演《我是芭比娃娃》。然后有多少人来了？大概两个教室满座的孩子，然后我的学前班老师就问：“为什么
I took it to the next level. Like I left my prep classroom and invited the whole school. I made ticket. That's fantastic. school to my performance of I'm a Barbie girl. And then how many people showed up? Like two classrooms full of kids and my prep teacher was like, why are
所有这些人都在这儿？”而且我委派了全班同学，我还让我班上所有我讨厌的男生都打扮成摄影师，假装是我的狗仔队。我妈妈来学前班接我，我想我的老师当时的表情就像是：你养大了一个有心理变态倾向的……这孩子
all these people here? And I commissioned my entire class and I'd made all of the guys that I hated in my class dress up as photographers and pretend to be like my paparazzi. And my mom came to pick me up from prep and I think my teacher was like, you have raised a psychopathic. Like, this child
是个自恋狂，是啊。才华有待商榷。组织能力。组织能力，而且这些一直支撑着你，你现在在日常生活中仍然在运用这些，因为我觉得你以前也会做同样的事，甚至可能更……乔玛，但我这周在悉尼时跟我妈聊过这个，关于我小时候什么时候开始搞一些小表演——我以前会表演一些小魔术，我还会扮演一些我喜欢的小电影里的场景。是啊，你做过那个吗？是啊，所以我还会跟我弟弟一起策划表演，
is narcissistic, yeah. Talent was questionable. Organization skills. organization and they have carried you through you continue to use those in your daily life nowadays because i feel like you would have done the same and maybe even you jo ma but i was having a conversation with my mom this week when i was up in sydney uh about when i used to put on little performances when i was a kid like i used to do little magic shows and i used to do little like act out little scenes from like like movies i like yeah did you do that yeah so i would commission performances with
是啊，而且我喜欢“策划”这个词，因为我确实……我雇了他。我会组织这些表演。我想我的父母可能对它们感到厌烦了。因为频率太高了。但我也录下来了……我爸会用他所有的录音设备，把海登和我唱歌的声音录下来。所以我们有海登和我大概五岁和三岁时唱《Love Shack》的录音，或者做一些那样愚蠢的事情。
my brother as well yeah and i love how commission yeah because i did i did i hire him. I would organise them. I think my parents were probably sick of them. They were having so frequently. But my dad also would record, like, songs of Hayden and I singing with all his, like, sound recording gear. So we have Hayden and I singing Love Shack at, like, you know, like, five and three or something stupid like that.
太搞笑了。因为我们唱了所有的声部。就像，而且是用全套的录音设备。《Love Shack》，宝贝。是啊。我的最爱。那个会在第21季播客里放出来吗？我很想看。
It's so funny. Because we do all of the parts. It's like, and it's on full, like, recording gear. Love Shad, baby. Yeah. My favorite. Is that coming out at the 21st? I love to see that.
我会很惊讶如果没有的话。安吉拉在听吗？如果她在听，我想看。我们需要跟爸妈协调一下。迪诺，把好东西交出来。我们要看《Love Shack》。10分钟加长版。
I would. be surprised if it didn't. Is Angela listening? If she's listening, I want to see it. We want to coordinate with mom and dad. Dino, give us the goods. We want to see the Love Shack. 10 minute version.
是啊。宝藏歌曲。是啊。你不懂。这是泰勒的风格。不，我不懂。对不起，又把你排除在外了。
Yeah. In the vaults song. Yeah. You don't get it. It's Taylor's with preference. No, I don't. I don't. Sorry, to exclude you again.
没关系。我以前办过你自己的假……好吧，有一张照片是我在举行一场假婚礼，我和我的狗结婚了。哦。你知道我养的那只狗吗？你知道我至今还放在床上的那个毛绒玩具狗吗？拿破仑。哦，所以不是真狗。
That's all right. I used to do your own fake. Well, there's a photo of me doing a fake wedding where I married my dog. Oh. You know that dog I have? You know the toy dog I still have on my bed? Napoleon. Oh, so wasn't a real dog.
不，是个毛绒玩具狗。这并不奇怪。是啊。其实还是稍微有点奇怪。而且我让我奶奶……我让我奶奶给我做了一套完整的、儿童尺寸的婚纱。哇，那太美了。还有头纱。
No, it was a toy dog. It was not weird. Yeah. It still was a little bit weird. And I made my grandma, I made my grandma make me a full, like, child-sized wedding gown. Wow, that's beautiful. And, like, a veil.
哦，你有照片吗？有，我会给你看。我会把它找出来。然后她还给我的狗做了一套。说来有趣，这有点像是一场女同婚礼，因为那只狗也穿着……好吧，也许我不该妄加揣测，但那只狗也穿着一件礼服和头纱。
Oh, is you a photo? Yeah, I'll show you. I'll find it for you. And then she also made my dog. Funnily enough, it was like a bit of a lesbian wedding with the dog because the dog was also wearing well maybe I shouldn't be presumptuous but the dog was also wearing a dress and a veil
哦，天哪，所以有两个新娘，其中一个是狗，另一个是我，所以严格来说……哦，天哪，我真是一个思想进步的人，谢谢。我是一个思想非常前卫的童养媳。我觉得如果是在……
oh my god so there was two brides one of which was a dog and one of which was me so technically oh my god I'm a very progressive thank you I was very progressive child I was a very progressive child bride I feel like we can forgive child brides if it's like
跟小孩结婚如果是支持LGBTQ的话，我们还是可以原谅童养媳的。那就像是一个LGBT的……是啊，是啊。那是个美好的时刻。那确实是个美好的时刻。我从一开始就是个同盟者。
in marrying children if it's like LGBTQ friendly That was like an LGBT Yeah Yeah That's a good moment It really was a good moment I've been an ally since day dot
是啊，我要把它……每个人都在首相面前。我需要去弄点同盟积分什么的。是啊，是啊，我一直、我一直……
Yeah I'm gonna put it Everyone from Prime Minister And I'm gonna need to get like Some brownie points that Yeah yeah I've always I've always
是啊，去参加所有的游行。甚至带上你的……你的爱人。我的爱人。是啊，拿破仑和那只狗。你的妻子。是啊，我觉得那非常……
Yeah go to all the parades Even bring your Your lover My lover Yeah Napoleon and the dog Your wife yeah I feel like that's very
像《公园与游憩》里的莱斯利。哦，天哪。当她和企鹅结婚的时候。我都忘了那一集了。哦，那些企鹅。是啊，是啊。当然，那挺搞笑的。
Pucks and Rec Like Leslie Oh my god When she marries the penguins. I forgot about that episode. Oh, the penguins. Yeah, yeah. And of course, that was quite funny.
引起了一阵轰动。是啊，跟那个……那个古板的女士，就是嫁给……我简直就是莱斯利。不。哦，你还真是个莱斯利。是啊。你简直就是个莱斯利。是啊。
It caused to be a stir. Yeah, with that, what's that, the uptight lady who's married to the... I'm such a Leslie Nope. Oh, you so are a Lesnarc. Yeah. You're a such a Lusselm. Yeah.
谢谢。我们希望如此。你觉得我是安·珀金斯，还是我是塔米？我不知道。哦，我的女儿。你是安。是啊，你是安。我觉得我不是安。
Thanks. We hope. Do you think I'm Anne Perkins or am I Tammy? I don't know. Oh, my daughter. You're Anne. Yeah, you're Anne. I don't think I'm Anne.
我觉得安稍微有点……不太像塔米。不，没人……你不是，是啊，没人像塔米那么坏。每个人身上都有点塔米的影子吧。也许我是戴安。是啊，是啊，戴安的。是啊。我觉得你有点像……抱歉，我要说出来了。
I think Anne is a little bit too. Not Tammy. No one's, you're not, yeah, no one's as bad as time. Everyone's good a little bit of Tammy in them, I guess. Maybe I'm Diane. Yeah, yeah, Diane's. Yeah. I think you're like, I'm sorry, I'm going to say it.
就像巨大的、聪明的安迪能量。是啊，我是，你完全就是安迪。不过我挺喜欢这样的。安迪有一些非常好的品质。是啊，我看得出来。也许有点克里斯的影子。安迪，安迪很可爱。我对此挺高兴的。
Like huge smart Andy energy. Yeah, I was, you're totally Andy. I like that though. Andy's got really nice qualities. Yeah, I can see that. Maybe a bit of Chris. Andy's, Andy's lovely. I'd be happy for that.
你会是个非常棒的安迪。而且安迪想像你一样当爸爸。确实。而且安迪内心深处也是个孩子，和你一样。是啊。我们扯得太远了。哦，对。我们确实扯远了。
You'd be a really good Andy. And Andy wants to be a dad like you. True. And Andy's a child at heart like you. Yeah. We got so sidetracked. Oh, yeah. We did, yeah.
你得把这段剪掉，是啊。不，这都是关于……好吧，那我们问最后一个问题。是啊，好吧，我们还有一个最后的问题。好吧。我们没有最后一个问题了。那这个呢？
You're going to have to cut this, yeah. No, it's all about the, okay, so we do one final question. Yeah, well, we have one final question. Okay. We don't have one final question. What about this one?
我跟这个女孩已经睡了几个月了……我不做那个。不，当然不。我们不谈那个。我不想回答那个问题。好吧，我们可以。不，我不做那个。好吧。
So I've been sleeping with this girl for a couple months now. I'm not doing that. No, of course not. We're not doing that. I don't want to answer that question. Well, we can. No, I'm not doing that. Okay.
不，你可以。抱歉，刚才听起来太有攻击性了。我不是故意那么有攻击性的。没关系。那是我们的前五个。是啊。以你们的专业意见，我们应该和前任保持朋友关系吗？哦，是啊，我觉得可以。
No, you can. Sorry, that sounded very aggressive. I didn't mean to be so aggressive. It's okay. That's our first five. Yeah. In your expert opinion, should we stay friends with our exes? Ooh, yeah, I think so.
其实这真的取决于关系的性质。是啊，这是个多么含糊的回答啊。是啊，是啊。这就像……就像，我觉得这几乎是能否成为朋友的前提条件。你和你的……其中一个前任是朋友吗？我是，是啊，我有个光谱。我跟其中一个前任是朋友。我和另一个关系挺好，然后我不……
Actually, it really depends on the nature of the relationship. Yeah, which is such a vague answer. Yeah, yeah. It like, like, I think that that is almost the condition of if you can be friends or not. Your friends with your, one of your exes? I'm, yeah, I've got a spectrum. I'm friends with one of my exes. I'm on good terms with another and then I don't.
其实，这真的取决于关系的性质。对啊，这个回答太模糊了。对，对。我觉得，这几乎是你们能否成为朋友的前提。你和你的前任之一是朋友吗？我，是的，我有不同的程度。我和其中一个前任是朋友，我和另一个关系很好，然后其他的就不是了。
speak to one of my other exes. I'm trying to feel in the blanks. Huh? Does that make sense? Yeah, yeah, it does make sense, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. What about you? I've got a two extreme spectrum. I've got to never look at me if you come within five feet of me.
跟我的其他前任聊聊。我只是想把空白的地方填上。啊？這講得通嗎？對，對，確實講得通，對。對，對，對。你呢？我有兩個極端的範圍。我有那種「如果你敢走進我五英尺以內，就別想看我一眼」。
I might try and throw you off something large. Very bad. And then I've got another extreme of like, we get along fine. Yeah. Yeah. We'd be happy to hang out. Yeah. Like I have no issues like you.
我可能會試著把你從某個巨大的東西上面推下去。非常糟。然後我還有另一種極端，就是像，我們相處得很好。對。對。我們很樂意一起出去玩。對。就像我對你沒有任何問題。
Good pals. Yeah, no beef. Because I think like fundamentally, and it's something, like, I remember getting coffee with my Moza recent ex after we broke up and be like, oh, wow, like I really, I miss her company a lot. We really go along well. And I think the reason why exes can be friends is because there's such a good baseline friendship there and banter that, like, you'll definitely get along with them.
好哥們。 yeah，沒有過節。因為我覺得根本上，這也是某種，就像，我記得在我最近一次分手後跟我的前任去喝咖啡，當時心想，噢，哇，我真的很想念她的陪伴。我們真的很合得來。我覺得前任之所以能成為朋友，是因為那裡有很好的友誼基礎和開玩笑的默契，所以你絕對能跟他們合得來。
It's just like, if it was a shift. relationship. Yeah. Yeah. And or it was a bad ending. Or if you still have feelings for them. Yeah. True.
只是就像，如果這是一段有問題的關係。對。對。而且或者這是一個糟糕的結局。或者如果你對他們還有感覺。對。真的。
That's another one. That is done. You cannot be friends with them. I have this. I, I'm either like, I, until my most recent ex,
這是另一種情況。那就完了。你不可能跟他們做朋友。我有這種情況。我，我以前一直是那種——直到我最近的這個前任——
I was like, when I finished something with someone I was seeing, I'm like, I do not speak to me anymore. Yeah. I don't like you. I don't want any part of you in my life.
我會覺得，當我跟某個我交往過的人結束關係時，我就會想：別再跟我說話了。對。我不喜歡你。我不要你介入我的生活。
Yeah. In some ways. I do a bit of back and forth. But that sucks, but I actually think that that's a really good baseline to have, right, because I think if you're too naive about it and you're like, I'm going to be friends with everyone who I've broken up with, it's like, okay, well, maybe re-evaluate that. Let's unpack.
對。從某些方面來說。我也會反反覆覆的。但這很糟，不過我其實覺得這是一個很好的基準，對吧，因為我覺得如果你對此太天真，覺得「我要和所有分手過的人做朋友」，那就，好吧，或許重新評估一下。我們來剖析一下。
Yeah, and it's also like the nature of the relationship doesn't have to, like, at least in my case, doesn't impact whether I'm not, I'm friends with them. I think, like, the worst breakup I had, like, I'm still friends. with that person out of the three relationships I've had. Yeah. Oh, interesting. Yeah. Which is nice. I'm still, I would say
對，而且這也像是關係的本質不一定——至少對我來說——不影響我是否能跟他們做朋友。我覺得，就像我經歷過最糟糕的分手，我還是跟那個人做朋友，在我的三段戀情之中。對。噢，真有趣。對。這挺好的。我還是會說，
I went through a period with my most recent accident. I don't feel weird talking about this because we've talked about it where I was like, went through this period of being like, I really do not like you. I, like, you are a terrible person. Don't speak to me anymore. But then when the time passes, you're like, oh, actually, like, we all make mistakes.
我和我最近的前任經歷過一段時期。我對於談論這個不覺得奇怪，因為我們已經談過了，當時我經歷了一段時期，心想：我真的很不喜歡你。我會覺得，你是個糟糕的人。別再跟我說話了。但後來當時間過去了，你會想：噢，其實，我們都會犯錯。
And you can become very good friends with them. But you have to be careful. Yes, you can. You have to be careful with it because you don't want to become reliant on them for emotional support again the way that you would have, if you're in a relationship with them. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. They are just another friend. Like,
而且你可以和他們成為很好的朋友。但你必須小心。是的，你可以。你必須對此小心，因為你不想再次依賴他們尋求情感支持，就像你以前和他們交往時那樣。對。對，對，對。他們就只是另一個朋友。就像，
I think it also matters the position that you were in prior to the relationship because I think the trap that a lot of people fall into is they were really good friends before they started dating. Then they started dating and there was a whole thing when they started dating about, oh, I didn't want to lose their friendship, etc., etc. And then they break up and they try. Ryan revert to that immediately and it always grows bad and it happens to so many people. That's interesting. I'm like, I definitely. Yeah, yeah. It's also like I totally get why, but also that's such a factor.
我覺得你們在交往之前處於什麼位置也很重要，因為我覺得很多人陷入的陷阱是，他們在開始約會之前就是很好的朋友。然後他們開始約會，在開始約會時有一大堆事情，像是「噢，我不想失去我們的友誼」等等、等等。然後他們分手了，他們試圖立刻回到過去那樣，而事情總是會變得很糟糕，這發生在太多人身上了。這很有趣。我就覺得，我絕對。對。對。我也完全理解為什麼，但這也是一個很大的因素。
And then I think the other key thing is time, right? Yeah, time, time's definitely the biggest one. Yeah, you're not going to be besties the next day. I mean, if you're trying to be. Yeah, there was a two-year gap between when I last spoke to one of my exes and then when we became friends. Yeah. Wow. Oh, that makes sense actually.
然後我認為另一個關鍵因素是時間，對吧？對，時間，時間絕對是最重要的因素。對，你不可能隔天就變成超級好閨蜜。我是說，如果你在試圖這樣做的話。沒錯，我跟我其中一個前任最後一次交談到我們成為朋友之間，隔了兩年。對。哇。噢，這其實說得通。
Yeah. And it's like, yeah. Yeah, yeah, and she just popped up and was like, want to grab coffee. I was like, yeah. I think that is actually makes an excellent point. You need to have had enough time to, like, with Jack and his old lady friend. Not old lady friend. No, no, no.
對。而且就像是。對，對，對，然後她突然出現，說：想去喝杯咖啡嗎。我就說：好啊。我覺得這確實提出了一個極佳的觀點。你需要有足夠的時間，就像傑克和他的老太太朋友。不是老太太朋友。不，不，不。
Yeah. Yeah. Mommy. My mommy. Kilt. Connecting with that last questioner. Yeah. Really.
對。對。媽咪。我的媽咪。Kilt。跟上一個提問者連線。真心的。
But like, you need to, you need to have had enough time to have been able to settle your resentments and to also have let feelings. lessened. Yeah. Because if you still have feelings for them, you're going to want from them what you wanted from them when you're in a relationship. Yeah.
但就像，你需要，你需要有足夠的時間來平息你的怨恨，同時也讓感情減弱。對。因為如果你對他們還有感情，你就會想從他們身上得到你在戀愛時想從他們身上得到的東西。對。
And it's not going to work. But then I do think in the long time you can be friends with your exes. I totally see myself being friends with my ex now. Yeah. Because we were such good friends when we were dating
而這行不通。但隨後我確實認為，從長遠來看，你可以和你的前任做朋友。我完全能想像自己現在和我的前任做朋友。對。因為我們在約會時是那麼好的朋友，
and now that things have been fixed. Yeah. We can just move. I don't know. Maybe I'm saying this and this is like in three months. I will be listening back to this. But it depends.
而現在事情已經修復了。對。我們可以就此向前看。我不知道。也許我現在這麼說，然後在三個月後。我會回頭聽這段話。但這取決於情況。
It just depends if you want to have a friendship with them. Yeah. Don't, you don't have to. Yeah, I think that's the other thing. If you can't be, if you can't be freaked and you have too many friends already,
這完全取決於你是否想和他們保持友誼。對。不用，你不需要。對，我覺得這是另一件事。如果你不能，如果你不能成為朋友，而且你已經有太多朋友了，
don't do it. Yeah. Because my whole thing is like I don't like the feeling of being like, I had this friendship with this person. I had this like, you, we really got along and then now we're on icky terms. Like that doesn't sit well with me.
那就別這麼做。對。因為我的全部觀點是，我不喜歡這種感覺，就像：我跟這個人有過這種友誼。我曾有過這樣的，我們真的很合得來，然後現在我們處於糟糕的關係中。這種感覺讓我坐立難安。
But I think I could definitely do the whole like, we're not in bad terms. They're not in good terms. We just. exist. I think it's just for me the ickiness. I just, I don't think I could cope with. Like, I feel like I'd have to sort of feel like things
但我認為我絕對可以做到那種「我們關係不壞。我們關係也不好。我們就只是存在著」。我覺得對我來說只是那種彆扭感。我只是，我覺得我無法應付。就像，我覺得我必須感覺事情至少已經平息了。
were at least settled. Yeah. I think you're right. Yeah, for sure. For sure. I'm a big fan of the block. Your block, yeah. Oh, yeah, the old block. He really does a trick. But then it makes things really weird. I'm a fan of the unfollow. So, you know, I like the unfollow too. Yeah. Yeah.
對。我覺得你是對的。對，沒錯。沒錯。我是「封鎖」的超級大粉絲。你的封鎖，對。噢，對，老封鎖。這真的很有用。但這會把事情弄得很詭異。我是「取消追蹤」的粉絲。所以，你知道，我也喜歡取消追蹤。對。對。
Just because otherwise it's too sad. Yeah. I just, anyone, yeah. I've been in a romantic relationship, or anything with, I'm always like, I just cannot interact with you for at least a while. Yeah. But then with time, time heals everything and then you can be in the same way as them. And then it's fun to stock them on social media. Yeah, yeah.
只是因為否則這太悲傷了。對。我只是，任何人，對。我曾有過戀愛關係，或任何事情的人，我總是會覺得：我至少有一陣子無法跟你互動。對。但隨著時間，時間會治癒一切，然後你可以用同樣的方式對待他們。然後在社群媒體上關注他們會很有趣。對，對。
Yeah, true, true, true. See, they've gotten other. Or on LinkedIn. Most of the new. Yeah. Yeah. All the people I've previously, like, dated or liked have all gotten really ugly. Yeah, see.
對，沒錯，沒錯，沒錯。看吧，他們有了別的。或者在LinkedIn上。大多數的新。對。對。所有我以前交往過或喜歡過的人現在都變得好醜。對，你看。
Sorry if you're listening, but it's true. Yeah. Well, I think it's also just the thing if you're not attracted to them anymore. Well, that's troubley one of this, isn't it? Yeah. Yeah. Not to point out the obvious. No, no.
如果你在聽的話很抱歉，但這是真的。對。嗯，我覺得這也只是如果你不再被他們吸引的問題。好吧，這絕對是其中之一，對吧？對。對。不用指出顯而易見的事。不，不。
And they're also rude. Yeah. And that was a joke. Like they haven't all gotten ugly. They're still very nice people. So, yeah.
而且他們也很粗魯。對。那隻是個玩笑。就像他們沒有全部變醜。他們仍然是非常好的人。所以，對。
Anyhow, we did some great. We covered some ground. We covered some ground. I'm really, and also, aren't we like three really wise people? Yeah.
不管怎樣，我們做得很棒。我們聊了很多。我們聊了很多。我真的，而且，難道我們不是三個非常聰明的人嗎？對。
This is quite cool. Three wise mice. Three wise mice. Yeah. Wait, is it three wise mice? I don't know. Three wise men.
這挺酷的。三隻聰明的老鼠。三隻聰明的老鼠。對。等等，是三隻聰明的老鼠嗎？我不知道。三位智者。
Three blind men. Oh, three blind mice. Yeah. Yeah. No, three wise mice is the cooler. If we had a cheeseboard, it would be complete. Three wise mice eating some green.
三隻瞎老鼠。對。對。不，三隻聰明的老鼠比較酷。如果我們有一個起司拼盤，那就完美了。三隻聰明的老鼠在吃一些綠色的。
We had the fattest feed before this though, so. We did. Yeah. Tofu out of 10? 11. Wow. It was pretty good. I had some mixed tofu.
不過在此之前我們吃得超飽的。我們吃了。對。豆腐打幾分？11分。哇。真的很好吃。我吃了一些綜合豆腐。
It was really nice. In fact, I think I had half of it. Thank you, Meg. Hi, Snickishnak. Yeah, a little shnickish snack. I've watched a bread. Um, yeah.
真的很好吃。事實上，我覺得我吃了一半。謝謝你，麥格。嗨，小點心。對，一小份鹹點心。我看了一塊麵包。嗯，對。
Anyhow, thanks for, thanks for, thanks for stopping in and asking questions. Yeah. How was your first podcast experience?
不管怎樣，謝謝，謝謝，謝謝你順道過來提問。對。你第一次的Podcast體驗如何？
I really enjoyed it. I really enjoyed it. I definitely couldn't do this by myself. Like I would be so, it's a lot harder by yourself. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
我真的很喜歡。我真的很喜歡。我絕對無法自己完成這個。就像我會覺得，自己一個人做難太多了。對。對。對。
I've enjoyed the chats. Yeah. Well, me too. This was really intriguing. Jack's a, now he's good. His master's,
我很享受這些聊天。對。嗯，我也是。這真的非常引人入勝。傑克的，現在他很棒。他的碩士，
he's done a second. Yeah. Because the first one I went on I was pretty nervous. Yeah. I think having a group here in person was a lot better. Because we did it over the phone the first time. Yeah.
他已經完成第二個了。對。因為我上第一次的時候其實很緊張。對。我覺得這裡有一個現場的團體會好很多。因為我們第一次是透過電話進行的。對。
Because it was locked down. It was kind of scary. You did really good though. It got really good feedback. Yeah. Yeah. You guys were really good to listen to. Yeah.
因為當時在封城。這有點可怕。不過你做得真的很好。獲得了很好的回饋。對。對。你們真的很好聽。對。
And I think it was because I knew so many of the stories as well that like or like I'd heard of them and like hearing you guys interact and talk about them was really sweet. Aw. Well now you got to make your debut. And I hope if you sent in a question, there was like maybe three or four that we didn't answer because they were just like a bit missed or not really questions. But if you did send in a no question. I hope we answered it well. Hope we didn't offend you. Hope that you got some solid advice.
而且我覺得這是因為我也知道很多這些故事，就像或者就像我聽過它們，而且聽你們互動並談論它們真的很甜美。噢。現在你得獻出你的處女秀了。我希望如果你寄了問題進來，大概有三四個我們沒有回答，因為它們有點漏掉或其實不算問題。但如果你真的寄了一個沒有問題的信。我希望我們回答得很好。希望我們沒有冒險你。希望你得到了一些扎實的建議。
Yeah. And also to the, I just want to do a quick shout out to the person who's in a situation ship. Yeah. Yeah, true. You're a queen. You're a queen.
對。而且也向，我只想快速向那個處於曖昧關係（situationship）中的人喊話。對。對，真的。你是個女王。你是個女王。
I don't know if it's a girl or a guy, but... I think that's important to mention, though. Yeah. Because like, it's... I'm feeling for you right now. Yeah. And you deserve a lot.
我不知道那是個女生還是男生……我覺得這還是值得一提的。對。因為就像，這……我現在對你感同身受。對。而你值得很多。
Yeah. Yeah. To all those people, you all deserve a lot. Rock climbing. Yeah, true. Rock climbing girl. Yeah. Was it a girl, a boy?
對。對。對所有那些人，你們都值得很多。攀岩。對，真的。攀岩女孩。對。那是個女孩，男孩？
It was a girl. Lonely, lonely person. Oh, that was, you need to. Thanks again for listening. Don't forget to subscribe. Wherever you, subscribe to this podcast, wherever you get your podcast. Jesus, Spotify and Apple Music. That was really beautiful.
是個女孩。孤獨，孤獨的人。噢，那是，你需要。再次感謝收聽。別忘了訂閱。無論你在哪裡，訂閱這個Podcast，無論你在哪裡收聽Podcast。天啊，Spotify和Apple Music。這真的很棒。
And follow us on Instagram as well. It's 20s, oh, Psych 20s podcast. I don't even know my own Instagram handle. And thanks for listening and thanks to, Jack and Meg again for joining us and we'll see you. Thanks a bit. It's fun. See you guys next week.
也在Instagram上追蹤我們。是20s，噢，Psych 20s Podcast。我甚至不知道我自己的Instagram帳號。謝謝收聽，也再次感謝傑克和麥格加入我們，我們下週見。謝謝一點。很有趣。大家下週見。
Bye. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more
拜。2%。這是當有自動扶梯可用時，仍然選擇走樓梯的人的比例。我是麥可·伊斯塔（Michael Easter）。在我的Podcast節目《2%》中，我們將剖析心理韌性、體適能以及在我們這個奇特現代世界中建立韌性的科學。經歷一些艱難，你將會以一個更快樂、更充實、更健康的自我走出另一端。
fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
收聽《2%》。也就是《TWO%》，在IHeartRadio應用程式、Apple Podcasts或您收聽Podcast的任何地方。在《Look Back at It》Podcast中。從1979年開始，對我來說那是個重大的時刻。84年對我來說也很重大。我是薩姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亞歷克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。
Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
每一集，我們挑選一個年份，剖析發生了什麼事，並試圖理解我們是如何度過那段時期的。與我們的朋友、喜劇演員同仁以及最喜歡的作家一起。像是馬克·拉蒙特·希爾（Mark Lamont Hill）談論80年代。84年是瘋狂的一年。那是瘋狂的一年。我認為對黑人來說，沒有比這更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio應用程式、Apple Podcasts或您收聽Podcast的任何地方收聽《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家最近怎麼樣？
You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast.
你正在收聽由你最喜歡的治療師兼主持人凱爾·蓋姆斯（Kear Games）主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。這個空間專注於黑人的經驗，進行坦誠的對話，這些對話在其他任何地方進行真的都不安全，但你是在跟一個知道自己在做什麼的持證專業人士進行對話。有多少男人攜帶著一副盔甲？它向世界發出信號，表明你不是好惹的。僅僅因為你有這個能力，並不意味著你需要這樣做。在IHard電台應用程式、Apple Podcasts或您收聽Podcast的任何地方收聽並學習《Learn the Hard Way》。這是一個IHart Podcast。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保證真人。這一集還沒有評論。點擊逐字稿中的任意句子來發表評論。